prepare for a job interview about deep
learning with this course from tdiv she
goes over 50 common interview questions
related to deep learning she's an
experienced data science professional
and has published papers in machine
learning scientific
journals I'm DF from luner Tech in this
course I'm going to teach you everything
that you need to know from the topic of
deep learning I'm going to help you
prepare for your deep learning
interviews we are going to answer answer
15 most popular deep learning questions
out there that you can definitely expect
if you are going to participate in data
science machine learning engineering but
alsoo AI engineering and research
scientist interviews deep learning is
one of the most popular topics this days
because it forms the Cornerstone of
topics such as large language models but
also the generative AI it contains many
complex Concepts it combines linear
algebra mathematics differental ition
Theory and also uh Advanced algorithms
and they all come together to form this
field of AI which is the fundamental
part of generative AI the large language
models so if you want to get a job in
large language models or geni then
definitely uh prepare for this type of
interviews because deep learning is
going to be a concept that your
interviews will test you for this course
I have specifically designed in such way
that we will go from very basic
questions to more advanced one so let's
first look into the first 50 questions
that we will be covering as part of this
course the first 10 will be the basic
concept so we will start uh very basic
we will talk about the concept of deep
learning uh what is the difference
between deep learning and machine
learning we'll also talk about the
concept of neural network we will look
into its architecture also what is the
concept behind neurons what is back
propagation how does it work how it is
different from GD what is GD what are
those different op optimizers we will
also be uh covering different activation
functions which are really important and
we will be covering them in detail to
also understand the concept of
saturation how this is causing Ving
gradient problem and also we'll be
covering the um different aspects of
just the entire training and testing
process behind neural
networks and then we will move towards
more complex uh topics and those will be
the next 10 questions so we will be
covering the concept of back propagation
in more detail the relationship with the
gradient descent and we'll be covering
the vanishing as well as the exploring
gradient uh problem we will also be
covering various uh question specific
and uh um problems related to deep
learning models that you will be asked
during your interviews we will also be
covering the loss function and a various
type of uh popular loss functions that
uh you can expect questions about during
your deep learning
interviews in the next 10 questions we
will be covering the following 10
questions so we will be covering the uh
SGD algorithm so more Advan version of
GD we will be covering the SGD with
momentum what is the role of this
momentum we will also be covering the
different versions and variants of GD
something that comes uh time and time
again during the Deep learning
interviews such as the badge GD mini
badge GD and the SGD
what is the difference between them what
is the function of bed size another very
popular question you can expect we are
also going to cover the idea of uh
Haitian uh how Haitian is being used as
part of different optimization
algorithms also what is the RMS prop and
what is the U Infamous Adam
algorithm then as part of the next 10
questions we will be covering bit more
complex uh topics we will be covering
the concept of Adam W and then we'll be
covering the batch normalization what is
the difference between batch and layer
normalization uh how layer
normalizations are used as part of
Transformers what is the residual
connection uh what is the function of
residual connections and we'll also be
talking about gradient clipping cier
initialization as well as the uh the
ways that we can solve vention gradient
problem and the exploding gradient
problem then we will also be covering
the concept of overfitting definitely
something that you can uh expect during
your deep learning interviews then as
part of the uh final 10 questions of
this part of the course we will be
covering the concept of Dropout and the
regularization in neural networks we
will be covering the uh overfeeding
problem and how it can be solved in
neural networks also what is the
difference between drop out and random
Forest so different tricky questions
that you can expect that have the goal
to confuse you but we will clear out
everything such that you don't need to
uh confuse anything during your
interviews then we'll be covering the
concept of uh the training versus
testing the adjustment when it comes to
Dropout we'll be covering the L1
regularization L2 regularization what is
the difference between them and the
impact on the weights uh the
penalization impact and difference how
severe they impact the uh moral
performance
we'll also be covering the concept of uh
curse of dimensionality and how deep
learning is solving this
problem then we will be covering the uh
concept of generative models honestly
more and more people are getting into
deep learning so whenever you want to
get into AI or in machine learning you
just want to start from the fundamentals
and to understand those more complex
models such as Transformers uh GPT
series T5 in order to understand those
mechanisms you need to know the basics
and those are the Deep learning
fundamentals something that we are going
to cover as part of this course because
once you know the fundamentals then you
will also be prepared to answer more
advanced questions and uh also to be
able to answer the follow-up questions
because during the Deep learning
interviews you are not only going to
answer the questions quickly and in a
scripted way but you will most likely
get those follow-up questions and I'm
going to help you with my detailed
explanations in such a way that you will
not only be prepared to a those uh basic
questions but also the corresponding
followup more advanced uh questions do
note that the idea of this course is not
to learn all the concepts from scratch
but instead to either quickly refresh
your memory from Deep learning or to uh
prepare for your deep learning
interviews and you already know the most
of these Concepts there are uh quite a
lot of complex uh topics that we will be
covering as part of deep learning and uh
I would suggest you to First refresh
your memory when it comes to statistics
machine learning and also various type
of mathematical Concepts such as the uh
matrix multiplication with linear
algebra differentiation Theory and then
get into uh this interview preparation
course when it comes to the uh
fundamentals to statistics if you want
to refresh your memory in this topic uh
before getting into this course I will
put a link uh that will forward you to
the fundamentals to statistics course as
part of lunar Tech where you will be
able to learn the statistical Concepts
or refresh your memory and when it comes
to machine learning my fundamental to
machine learning handbook uh from free
Cod camp or uh fundamentals to machine
learning course as part of ltech boot
camp will be able to help you to either
learn or refresh your machine learning
memory and once you have done that all
then you are ready to conquer your deep
learning interviews I hope you guys will
stick around cuz this course is going to
be very helpful for anyone who wants to
prepare for deep learning interviews so
if you're ready I'm really excited so
let's get started so the first question
is what is deep learning so in this
question your interviewer wants to
understand whether do you have an
understanding where the Deep learning
comes in comparison to machine learning
in comparison to AI and you can briefly
mention about the idea of neural
networks and how it is related to human
brain so deep learning is a subset of
machine learning which is then a subset
of AI so a branch of artificial
intelligence which involves training
artificial neural networks on large
amount of data in order to identify and
learn those hidden patterns nonlinear
relationships in a data which is
something that the traditional machine
learning models like linear regression
or logistic regression or random forest
and exus are not doing so well as the
Deep learning models and the the heart
of deep learning is the concept of
layers because the artificial neuron
networks and just in general the Deep
learning tries to replicate uh the way
human brains work and the way we
intercept the and take the input signals
from outside world when we see something
or hear something or smell something and
then use that information in order to
learn and in order to whether to make
conclusions or to do something and
that's exactly what deep learning tries
to do it tries to use this idea of naral
networks which are deep learning models
in order to take the input data in the
input layer and then transform this
through the activation functions to
activate these neurons and then
transform it into into activations and
this will be in our hidden layers and
the magic happens in a deep learning
model to identify the nonlinear
relationships in the input data and then
what it does is that it produces then
the output so this is at a very high
level the interviewer doesn't want you
to explain the idea of Weights the idea
of parameters which we will talk about
later but then the intervie wants to
know whether you have higher level
understanding what this deep learning is
and maybe also to keep a few examples of
deep learning models definitely mention
this relationship between the way the
human brains and the and the neural
networks you specify this idea of input
data input signals and activations and
hidden layer don't go too much into
detail of the architecture of neural
networks and do briefly mention that the
that these deep learning models examples
of deep learning models are for instance
artificial neural networks uh reur
neural networks lstms the different
sorts of more advanced architecture such
as variational outo encoders they're
also based on neural networks you get
the idea so if I were to answer this
question very short I would just say
that deep learning models are a subset
of machine learning models on its turn a
branch of artificial intelligence that
tries to learn complex data and large
amount of data and discover hm patterns
and complex structure in this pattern
for various type of tasks including
computer vision including a machine
translation task lot of NLP models um
the INF famous Chad gbt so gbt models or
T5 all these large language models they
are all based on Neal networks and they
are deep learning models so the next
question is how does de learning differ
from the traditional machine learning
models here your interview wants to
understand whether you know what are the
main advantages of the deep learning
models compared to machine learning
model models so do mention a few
examples of traditional machine learning
models and then mention a few examples
of deep learning models and try to put
the focus on one or two advantages of
the deep learning models so a few
examples of machine learning models are
linear regression logistic regression
the support Vector machines KN viation
algorithm K means or clust string so as
an unsupervised learning model theb scan
do mention few boosting algorithms such
as GBM XG boost you can also mention
random Forest very popular for
regression as well as classification
type of tasks so in this way you will
show to your interviewer that you know
quite quite well those machine learning
algorithms then do mention the Deep
learning models which fundamentally
differ from the machine learning models
and I mention examples such ASN RNN LS
grus and outter encoders all base or
neural networks do also mention CNN so
convolutional neural networks very much
popular in the field of computer vision
then do point out that the first biggest
difference is that uh traditional
machine learning models they rely on
manual feature extraction while deep
learning models they do this
automatically and they automatically
take the input data as it is we don't
need to perform feature selection we
don't need to worry about that because
our model represented by neural networks
especially with this D players is able
to identify this patterns in all this
data and then extract for itself the
most important features that describe
our data and then use it for different
type of tasks whether it's for
regression for classification it
actually performs very well so deep
learning models perform very well on Big
Data something that we have seen machine
learning models suffer so ml models are
known for becoming worse in terms of
their performance when the size of the
data increases when the number of
features increases they start to
overfeed and they start also to become
unstable and not accurately predict the
output when we increase the number of
observations in our data also the
include complex features in the data
that's something that definitely helped
the de learning models outperform the
traditional machine learning models
especially in the test such as computer
vision or speech recognition machine
translation and the idea of deep
learning models you can even see why
they are better than a machine learning
models by even looking at the most
recent different sorts of applications
in the across different Tech Fields you
can see that most of them are based on
some sort of Naro network based
algorithm rather than machine learning
models and this is mainly because of
this various abilities of deep learning
models including ability to handle large
data ability to handle complex features
and being able to do feature extraction
on itself instead of doing it outside of
the model or um instead of suffering
from various type of problems like the
traditional machine learning models do
so the next question is what is a neural
network so here your interior wants to
understand the relationship ship between
the neural networks to to the human
learning the way we learn and whether
you know this components and how the
components uh flow so in terms of the
training process whether do you know
what the weights are what the parameters
are whether you know what this hidden
layers are whether they they are just
one or multiple you understand the
concept of deep neural networks and how
this flow of information happens and
whether you mention all the these
elements of the neural networks so I
would mention as an answer to this
question that neural networks is a
foundational Concept in the field of
deep learning and in the field of
artificial intelligence just in general
and it's a computational model that is
inspired by biological human brains and
it tries to replicate the way humans
learn the way they interpret information
they take the input data and they they
process that information so they do
training of the on the input data and
they also consistently update on this
information so they learn something new
they add new information and then they
update the the possible outcome and the
end result is to minimize the amount of
error we are making when we are learning
and that's exactly what we are doing in
neural networks so the core of neuron
network is made up of this units which
we are calling neurons like in our human
brains and uh these neurons are together
together forming the layers we have
input layer which is in our which
represent our input data then we have
this the the weights which showcase how
much importance we need to put on
different input signals and this weights
are what we are calling parameter in our
model which we need to consistently
update when we are performing the
training so the learning process
so these layers include the input layer
one or more hidden layers which is the
middle part of our naral Network and
that helps to learn these different
patterns helps to understand activate
certain neurons and deactivate or
activate less the other input neurons
and then transforms this information
after this activations are done we go
through this hidden layer and in after
this hidden layer then we can have
another hidden layer which will then
receive the information from the
previous hidden layer and will then
continue the learning process on it
certain it will be able to learn and
understand the previous hidden layers
information and as an example of this
process think of that in the input we
have the different pixels of the images
and we want to learn these images and
for the model for the nural network to
learn it should be able to First learn s
some sort of objects in the input data
so in the first hidden layer it might
discover certain signals certain edges
and certain information and then in the
next hidden layer it will be able to
identify specific objects for instance
the the ears of a cat if we want to
identify where the image is of a cat or
a dog and then passes this information
onto your next layer onto the next layer
and then we go on to the final layer
when we produce the output now now if
you are familiar with machine learning
and if you are looking at this tutorial
I assume that you are familiar with the
idea of classification regression on
supervised learning supervised learning
so the in case of the traditional neural
networks we then produce the output and
it can be for instance identifying a
probability a value between zero and one
let's say for our classification task
and then this value should be compared
uh to the actual class so if we have for
instance probability and we transform it
to the class then we can update the
corresponding so we have the output of
our neuron Network in each Epoch and
then we use this information to compare
to the true labels in our supervised
learning process and then we compute the
error so we are trying to understand how
well we did our prediction and then this
information is being used to then
understand how moral is being how
accurately is the model predicting the
results and this then this is what we
are calling loss so this loss function
is then used in order to understand how
much we need to change the weights so
how much importance we put on the
neurons how much we need to update these
weights as well as the other parameters
in our model in order to reduce the
amount of error moral is making and
that's the underlying idea of neural
networks to take the input put it
through those hidden layers to learn
from this input data activate the
neurons and have either one hidden layer
or multiple hidden layers continuously
activate those neurons get the output
understand what is the loss that our
model is making the overall cost
function and then compute the what we
are calling gradients and do briefly
mention here the idea of gradients but
do not go too much into detail of it and
then using this grip radians we
understand how much we need to update
this weights in order to improve our
prameters of our model because at the
end of the day what we care about for
our final result is this model that has
the parameters the weight parameters the
paramet the bias parameters that will
end up generating the most accurate
predictions for us and for that we need
to continuously learn go through this
Loop in order to properly learn and in
order to produce a model that makes the
minimum amount of error so it's able to
properly learn from the input data the
next question is explain the concept of
neon in deep learning in this question
the interview wants to hear about the
concept of Weights the concept of bias
factors how they are used in order to
uptain the so-called Z scores and how
the activations are activ ation
functions are used to obtain activations
and what is the point of this weights
and Bas vectors and relationship to the
learning process so a neuron in a deep
learning it is referred as sometime
sometimes referred as artificial neuron
which mimics the function of the human
brain's neuron but it does so in
mathematic and simple way and the idea
is that in a neural
network the moral gets different
inputs and here this input signals we
are calling neurons it takes the input
data which we represent and call it as
an X and we use this x to multiply it by
weights because this weights can then
tell us how much importance this neuron
should have how much attention we need
to pay to this neuron and these weights
are then multiplied by this input data
which you call X those are the neurons
and we add a bias Factor because there
can be always a bias introduced when we
are performing our learning process and
the the way it's multiplied by this
input data X we are adding then on the
top of that the bias factors and this
will be our Z scor but then in the next
stage before approaching the hidden
layer we use what we are calling
activation functions and activation
function such as sigmoid function
Rectify linear unit or
leyu all this activation functions what
they are doing is that they are
mathematically introducing nonlinearity
into our neural network and these
activation functions are applied to all
these different Z scores which is based
on the weights and then input data and
bias vectors in order to understand how
much each neuron should be activated it
can be that we want in certain when when
looking at the object and trying to
understand what is the object in that
image based on the pixels it can be that
we need to activate certain neurons
related to that specific area or that
specific object and we should not
activate the other neurons and that's
exactly what we are doing with this
activations of this neurons so here then
we are using these activations to
introduce non larity for neural network
to learn this complex structures in the
input data so the next question is
explain architecture of neural networks
in simple way given that we have already
answered the previous questions all
mentioning some parts of the
architecture and the training process of
Naro networks this one will be easy to
answer and I will use here a simple
visualization for simple Naro networks
that consist of just one hidden layer to
just summarize everything that we
mentioned as part of previous interview
questions so the nural network is this
multi-layer structured model and each
layer is transforming the input data
step by step think of it like an
assembly line so assembly line where
every stage adds more complexity on the
preview stage and the detail and the
complexity is adding more value to the
ability of the model to perform
predictions so in the beginning the the
model has this input layers as you can
see here the input layers are
represented by this Z1 Z2 Z Tre up until
z n and in here you can think of this
elements this inputs as part of input
layer as features describing the data so
it can be for instance that we want to
use use neural network to uh estimate
the price of a house we need to have
certain features to estimate that price
we need to learn and in order to
understand how we can differentiate
different houses and how these features
influence the house price so Z1 can be
for instance the number of bedrooms of
this house Z2 can be the the number of
levels of this house that tree can be
the whether the house has a swimming
pool or not not a can be uh whether the
house was built so what is the year that
the house was built what is the age of
the house all these features they
describe a certain element or certain uh
characteristic of the house and this
will help us and this will help the
moral to learn from this feature and to
understand what will be possible
accurate price price for this house and
then we have these different weights as
you can see uh we have weight one one
weight one two weight 1 three and then
we have the corresponding weights for
the second input the corresponding
weights for the for our third feature so
corresponding to Z3 such as w31 w32 and
w33 Etc as you can see this weights they
show a pile that goes an arrow that goes
onto the next layer which is our hidden
layer so in this simple architecture we
have just we got just one hidden layer
but it can also be that you have more
hidden layers which is usually CA the
case with the traditional deep neural
networks hence also the name deep so
what this weights do is that they help
us to understand how much this input
feature should contribute to First
hidden unit second hidden unit and third
hiding unit so as you can see in our
hidden layer we have the three circles
these three circles describe the hidden
units in our hidden layer and we have
the simple structure so we got just
three hidden units but this is something
that you can decide for yourself when
training your model it's also what we
are calling hyper parameter that you can
tune so in here that you can see that
the w11 goes from Z1 to H1 so this is
the importantance weights that tell us
and tell to the narrow Network how much
the input layer should get attention
when should get importance when it when
it helps you learn the first heing unit
so for H1 what is the weight that we
need to put on Z one so our first
feature then we have the W12 which
describes the amount of weight that we
need to put on the first input feature
when identifying this when learning and
putting the information into our second
hidden unit H2 so you get the idea so
then this this weights and the
corresponding bias factors and the input
data helps us to compute what we are
calling Z scores and Z score so Z can be
represented as the W so the weight
multipli by X which is the previous in
this case the input data plus bias
Vector which we sometime refer as B then
once we have the Z scores we are then
ready to add an nonlinearity so the
activations which will then help us to
understand how we need to perform
aggregation so you can see that when it
comes to the first hitting unit H1 there
are four different piles so arrows that
comes to H1 it is the w11 W uh 21 w31
and
wn1 what this basically means is that we
have this different input features and
per input feature we have the
corresponding weight that helps us to
understand how much attention we need to
pay on these different input features
when we are obtaining the H1 so our
hidden layers first hidden unit and we
can aggregate these different Z scores
that we compute based on different
weights different input signals and this
activation function can significantly
change on the way we calculate our
activations in the H1 and that's exactly
what the activation does so the
activation functions then once we have
this information we have computed our
activation we are ready to compute our
output and the output is done after we
have computed our H1 H2 and H3 those
hidden units have learned based on the
weights and bi factors and activation
function the information in our input
data in the previous layer then we use
the final so the final weights so uh wh1
wh2 wh3 in order to understand how much
each hidden unit need to contribute to
the output layer and in this output
layer what we are doing is that we are
getting the output in the format that is
desired so it can be that we are
performing classification and we want to
get a
probability uh therefore we need to
obtain a value between 0 and one then in
this output layer we will then have this
volue we will transform it to a class
and we will compare it to the true label
such as zeros and ones you understand
how well our simple neural network is
performing so the next question is what
is an activation function in neural
networks so activation function in
neural network plays a crucial role and
the choice of activation function will
uh Define the performance of your neural
network we by now have already spoken a
lot about the weights and how we compute
the Z scores using the weights the input
data or the previous layers input a
previous layers output we add the bias
vectors to obtain the Z scores and then
we need to apply activation function to
obtain the activation so how much each
neuron should be activated when
Computing the next layer so that is
exactly what activations do so
activation functions they uh in neural
network they introduce the idea of
nonlinearity if we were to not use
specific type of activation functions
they will our model will be similar to
the uh linear regression model we will
have a plain linear type of model that
will be able to uncover the linear
patterns and will not be able to uh
discover these complex hidden patterns
in the data and we have seen that in the
true world the data most of the time
contains nonlinear relationships
therefore we introduce the activation
functions which help us to introduce
nonlinearity into our neural network and
they are like aggregation functions that
help us to understand how we need to
combine this different input this this
different neurons corresponding Z scores
in order to obtain final so single
activation volume so in here if you look
at this figure here you can see that we
are using the X1 X2 up until xn which
are our input points and then we have
the corresponding weights which tell us
how much each of these inputs need to be
activated and then we need to aggregate
these values we need to obtain one
single activation which will be then
based on the activation function it will
it basically defines how much we need to
add a value that corresponds to that
specific input when Computing the hidden
units volume that we saw before and
there are different sorts of activation
functions do mention briefly that the
four popular activation functions are
sigmoid activation function the hyperb
hyperbolic tank function uh which
shortly is referred as Tang function
also definitely mentioned about
rectifier linear unit activation
function so the REO and also mention the
Leaky relo so the Leaky of the rectifier
linear unit activation function you can
also if you have time you can also
specify that activation functions they
act like a Gatekeepers so they decide
how much information needs to be used
from this from this state to be passed
upon to onto the next state so that's
basically the idea behind activation
functions which enable the neural
networks to properly learn nonlinear
relationships in the data the next
question is name few popular activation
functions and describe them so we
briefly spoke about activation functions
in the question number six so here I
will go into much more detail about
these different activation functions and
we'll also make a categorization between
them when you are getting asked this
question you don't need to give all
these different sorts of examples just
one example of out of this four and then
provide this detailed explanation of
this specific activ ation function but
in this case what I would do is that I
will provide you all four four popular
activation functions largely used in the
industry and then it will be up to you
to decide which one you will give as an
example so I tend to make this
categorization behind this four
activation function so sigmoid
activation function Tang activation
function rectifier linear unit or short
relu activation function and the leak
key rectifier linear unit Rel the
activation function so uh I tend to say
that sigmoid function and Tang function
they are they can form a single category
and then the rectifier linear unit and
its adjusted version Le youru they can
form the second category of activation
functions and we will soon see why so
let's now start with the sigmoid
activation function so if you are
familiar with the logistic regression
then you most likely will recognize this
activation function because sigo
function is also used in logistic
regression when we are trying to produce
values that are like probabilities so
values between zero and one so as you
can see in case of sigmoid activation
function we are getting the this s
shaped curve when it comes to the
diagram that describes the activation
functions and so what goes into
activation function we are Computing the
Z scores which are them based on the uh
on the previous layers data so output it
can be for instance described by X and
then we are multiplying this x by the
weights let's say w and then we are
adding bias Factor let's say B and then
we this helps us to get the Z scores
then the Z scores needs to be used and
put given us an input into the
activation function and this is exactly
then what transforms the Z scores into
activation function and here it is the
sigmoid activation function so sigmoid
activation function then takes the input
let's say Z and then what it does is
that it transforms into this value where
the value is 1 / to 1 + e to the power
minus Z so similar to what we do in
logistic regression and as you can see
what this graph represents which is a
sigo function in the x axis we have all
the Z scores basically and in the y AIS
we have the corresponding activations
and you can see that for all the values
from minus infinity till plus infinity
for the exis so for the Z scores the
corresponding Activation so on the Y AIS
we have values between zero and one so
the minimum is zero and the maximum is
one so you can see that the inflation
point so the point where we go when we
flip the uh the curve is at
0.5 and this activation function uh you
can see that whenever we have a negative
values then the corresponding
activations will be between zero and 0.5
it is all these areas and whenever we
have the Z scores which are positive
scores the corresponding so if if we
have positive scores for our Z scores
then the corresponding activations will
be between 0.5 and then one what is
really important to remember and
mentioned during your answer as part of
the interview question is that sigmoid
function is suffering from what we call
saturation so what is saturation so
saturation happens when when we take a
very large negative values or very large
positive values um then the activation
or the volue in this case of a function
converges to the extremes of the
corresponding function and this is
exactly what happens here if we look
here if we take let's say the x equals
to minus 1,000 then the corresponding y
will be most likely very close to zero
and which is the minimum so it's the
extreme of the of this activation
function and if we take the X as a very
large positive number like plus 1,000
then the corresponding activation value
will be very close to one which is then
the global maximum of this function so
this is exactly what we refer as
saturation so it means that if we take
very large negative or very large
positive number for our Z scores this
activation function will then provide us
an output a value that is very close to
the extreme so two extremes the uh zero
and the one of the corresponding
activation function and later on we will
see why this can be problematic if we
use this function as part of our
activations for the hidden layers but of
course when it comes to getting a value
an output between 0 and one
which is exactly what the sigmoid
function is doing then the sigmoid
function would be the goto activation
function so the next activation function
that we will talk about is the
hyperbolic tank activation function ins
shorted tank function so as you can see
the hyperbolic tank function is quite
similar in its shape to the sigmoid
activation function only what it does
different is that it transforms all the
values to value between minus one and 1
instead of 0 and one like the sigmoid
function was doing so the tank function
as the name suggests it's based on the
idea that comes from uh geometric topics
if you are familiar with the idea of
sinus cosine is T tangent and cotangent
then this will be familiar to you
because this function does exactly that
so it's uses this tank function to
transform all the Z scores to volue that
is between minus1 and one so the F set
which represents the dis activation
function is a function that is equal to
uh in denominator we have e^ Z minus e^
minus Z / to e to^ z + h^ minus Z so
what it basically does is that it
transforms it takes the Z sores and if
the Z scores are negative it transforms
to the values between minus one and zero
and then if the Z SES are positive
numbers from zero to plus infinity then
the corresponding activations will be
between zero and one and as in case of
sigmoid function tank function also is
s-shaped uh only the inflation point so
the point where it changes its pattern
the way the graph behaves is not at the
0.5 but it's at a point of zero like
sigmoid function tank function also
suffers from saturation so for large
negative and large positive numbers the
corresponding activations will be very
close to the extreme point so the minus
one and + one uh for this function which
can be problematic like in case of
sigmoid function so don't use these two
functions for your hidden layers but use
them for the output layer and we use
them for the output layer simply because
the the value that we are getting from
these two functions is very convenient
to to transform it to the corresponding
value whether it's for instance
classification case because if we get a
value between 0o and one for instance as
in case of sigo activation function then
we can interpret this as probability and
this probability can be then used for
getting a class so class zero and one
for for instance and this then can be
used for evaluating our model by
comparing it to the actual classes and
compute the cross entropy or any other
uh valuation metrics can be computed
based on this and later on we will see
why this two activation functions should
not be actually used in the hidden
layers especially for deep neural
networks that have many hidden layers
but for now as this is out of the scope
of this question I don't want to go into
details as we have already covered quite
a lot so the next two activation
functions that you can mention when
answering this question uh can be the
rectifier linear unit and the Ley
rectifier linear unit activation
functions the two are very similar
especially when it comes to the positive
Z scores but they are bit different when
it comes to the negative Z scores so
what do I mean by this when we look at
the rectifier linear unit so re
activation function you can see that uh
it looks like this so it takes for all
the cases when Z so the
activation if the Z score is small than
zero so it's a negative number then the
corresponding activation will be zero so
basically uh this activation function
will not be activating any of the
negative
neurons whereas the for for the cases
when we have the Z scores positive then
the corresponding activations will be
exactly equal to the Z scores so hence
the name linear so if you look at the Y
is equal to X line and you visualize
that line you can see that the positive
part so for the part where the x is is
positive from zero to plus infinity you
can see that that Y is equal to X line
is exactly like that exactly what we
have here and that's where the the name
linear comes from so it's like the
linear function representation but this
only holds for the positive numbers so
for positive numbers we will get the the
Z scores and we will activate them by
their exact amount whereas in case of
negative Z scores or negative neural
then the corresponding activation will
not happen and we will not be activating
these negative values and for all these
cases the activation function will set
the activation equal to zero so this can
be uh problematic for the cases when we
do want to have the output we do want to
take into account these negative values
and we want to uh consider these
negative values and perform the
predictions based on them too in those
cases we need to adjust this re so we
can then better use what we are calling
leaky relo and what this leaky relu
activation function does is that it not
only activates the positive sores but it
also activates the negative ones it does
that at a lesser extreme than the for
the cases when d z is positive of course
as you can see from this from this
negative side so for from this third
quarter of our graph but it still does
it and you can see it also from the
function itself because the activation
function corresponding to Liu can be
represented by this F set which is equal
to
0.01 if Z is smaller than zero and is
equal to Z if Z is larger than equal
zero so for all the positive numbers the
liid ru acts exactly the same as for Ru
as you can see here but for the negative
values the corresponding activation is
simply equal to
0.01 so you can see that it is this part
of the figure so both of this activation
functions do not suffer from saturation
something that is definitely different
compared to the sigmoid and tank
function and that's why it is
recommended and it has been proven that
this two activation functions perform
much better when we use them as part of
our uh hidden layers activations and
they are not so much used when it comes
to our output layer so think of like
using the Leaky Rel and re for your
hidden layers but not to use them for
your output layer and the other way
around for the sigo function tank
function use them for for your output
layer but not for your hidden layers so
the next question is what happens if you
do not use any activation functions in a
neural network so the answer for this
question can be very short because it is
quite obvious so the AB of activation
functions will reduce the narrow Network
to a common machine learning model like
linear regression something that removes
the entire idea of using neural networks
in the first place therefore in order to
be able to utilize the architecture of
neural networks and to be able to
discover hidden patterns in our data
nonlinear patterns we can use the
activation functions and nonlinear
activation
function the next question is describe
how training of basic neural networks
work so in this case your interviewer
wants to know whether you know the idea
of a forward pass backward pass what is
back propagation how this processes are
connected to each other and how neural
networks utilize these layers in order
to learn these complex patterns in your
data so you can start by uh describing
the training process of naral network a
very basic one uh by the process of what
we are calling forward path forward path
takes the input data and processes
through neurons which we saw before and
uses this weighted sum and activation
functions to produce an output so we
take the input data we multiply it by
the corresponding weights and then we
add a bias Factor then those are our Z
scores then we apply an activation
function to introduce
nonlinearity and this activated values
the activation scores then are used when
we are passing information onto the next
layer because then we are using this as
our input we are multiplying it by the
corresponding weights we are adding the
bias factors and then uh we are using
activation function for that hidden
layer in order to learn from this
complexities this process continues on
until we reach the output layer where we
compute our output so this output is
then used to compare it to the True
Values that we have for our data so it
can be for instance the true labels of
our observations in a classification
problem then we compute what we are
calling a loss function or cost function
it can be for instance the rmsc or MSC
for regression type of problem it can be
for instance cross entropy for class
ification type of problem and then using
this loss function we are then doing
what we are calling back propagation
back propagation is then process of
computing the gradients so the first
order derivative of this loss function
with respect to the weights and the bias
Vector so with respect to the parameters
of our model that we want to improve and
once we have computed this gradient
which tell us how much our L function
will change if we make a certain change
to our our weights and to our parameters
so the bias vectors then we can use this
gradients in order to update our
parameter in our model and the way we
are doing that is by the process of
backward pass so this is the opposite of
what we are doing in the forward pass in
the forward pass we go from left to the
right till the end of the model to get
the output in the backward pass we do
the opposite so we basically we're going
backwards we have identified the
gradients by doing back propagation then
we are using these gradients we are
giving it as an input tune optimization
technique it can be SGD GD SGD with
momentum RMS probe Adam you name it and
then using that approach in order to
update our weights and our bias factors
uh layer by layer so then what we are
basically doing is that uh we are taking
the gradients we are taking the
optimization algorithm that we will use
let's say Adam and then we are updating
the weights corresponding to the last
layer we have computed that then we go
on to the next layer that comes before
so in this way we go from right from
very deep layers to the left one so from
using the multiplications between the
weights and in this way we are then
using the gradients and we are updating
the weights and the bias factors in such
way that we can adjust the weights and
then reduce the loss function so this is
very important to mention and to show
the interviewer that you understand why
we are updating the weight and why we
are updating the bias vectors because
mathematically the gradients show how
much change will be in the loss function
when we change a certain weight or
certain bias Factor by certain amount it
can be small amount and that is
something that we are using the
gradients uh in order to update the
previous weight parameters and bias
parameters such that we can reduce the
loss that our motor is making because
this will mean that we are one step
closer to having more accurate model the
smaller amount of error we are making
the smaller is our loss the better is
our neural network performing so that's
the idea behind training of the neural
networks and this Pro continues on and
on we have forward pass back propagation
backward pass and on and on until we
have reached some sort of uh end
criteria so stopping criteria let's say
the number of iterations number of epo
or some other stopping criteria the next
question is what is gradient descent so
gradient descent is an optimization
algorithm that we are using in both
machine learning and in deep learning in
order to minimize the loss function of
our model which which means that we are
iteratively improving the model
parameters in order to minimize the cost
function and to end up with a set of
model parameters that will that will
optimize our model and the model will be
producing highly accurate predictions so
in order to understand the gradient
descent we need to understand what is
the loss function what is the cost
function which is another way of
referring to the loss function uh we
need to also understand the the flow of
nural network how the training process
works uh which we have seen as part of
the previous questions and then we need
to understand the idea of iteratively
improving the model and why we are doing
that so let's start from the very
beginning so we have just learned that
during the training process of naral
network we first do the forward pass
which means that we are iteratively
Computing our activations so we are
taking our input data we then are
passing it with the corresponding weight
parameters and the bias vectors through
the hidden layers and we are activating
those neurons by using activation
functions and then we are going through
those multiple hidden layers up until we
end up with uh Computing the output for
that specific forward path so the uh
predictions why hat so once we perform
this in the for our very initial
iteration of training the neural network
we need to have a set of model
parameters that we can start uh training
process in the first place so we
therefore need to initialize those
parameters in our model and we have
specifically two type of model
parameters in the naral network we have
the weights and we have the bias factors
as we have seen in the previous
questions so then the question is well
how much error are we making if we are
using this specific set of ways and bias
vectors cuz those are the parameters
that we we can change in order to
improve the accuracy of our model so
then the question is well if we use this
very initial version of the model
parameters so the weights and the B
vectors and we compute the output so the
Y hat uh then we need to understand how
much error is the model making based on
the set of model parameters that's the
loss function so loss function or the
cost function which means the average
error that we are making when we are
using this weight and the bias factors
in order to perform the
predictions and uh as you know already
from the machine learning we have
regression type of tasks and
classification type of tasks based on
the problem that you are solving you can
also decide what kind of loss functions
you will be using in order to measure
how well your model is doing and the
idea behind narrow Network training
process is that you want to iteratively
improve this moral parameters so the
weights and bias factors such that uh
you will end up with the set of best and
most optimal waste and the bias factors
that will result in the smallest amount
of error that the model is making which
means that you came up with an algorithm
and with neural network that is
producing highly accurate predictions
which is our goal our entire goal by
using neural networks so loss functions
if you are dealing with classification
type of problems can be the cross
entropy which is usually the go to
Choice when it comes to the
classification type of tasks but you can
also use the F1 score so F beta score
you can use the Precision Recall now
beside this in case you have a
regression type of task you can also use
the mean Square the MSC you can use the
rmsc you can use the MAA and those are
all the ways that you can measure the
performance of your model every time
when you are changing your model
parameters so we have also seen as part
of the training of of neural network
that there is one fundamental algorithm
that we need to use which we called and
referred as a back propagation that we
use in order to understand how much is
there a change in our loss function when
we apply a small change in our
parameters so this is what we were
referring as gradients and this came
from mathematics and as part of the back
prop what we were doing is that we were
Computing the first order partial
derivative of the loss function with
respect to each of our model parameters
in order to understand how much we can
change each of those parameters in order
to decrease our loss function so then
the question is how exactly gradient
descent is performing the optimization
so the gradient descent is using the
entire training data when going through
one pass and one iteration as part of
the training process so for each update
of the parameters so every time it wants
to update the weight factors and bias
vectors it is using the entire training
data which means that in one go in one
forward path we are using all the
training observations in order to
compute our predictions and then compute
our loss function and then perform back
propagation compute our first order
derivative of the loss function with
respect to each of those model
parameters and then use that in order to
update those parameters so the way that
the GD is performing the optimization in
updating the model parameters is taking
the output of the back prop which is the
first order partial derivative of the
loss function with respect to the moral
parameters and then multiplying it by
the Learning rate or the step size and
then subtracting this amount from the
original and current model parameters in
order to get the updated version of the
model parameters so as you can see here
this comes from the previously showcased
simple example from neural network and
here when we compute the predictions we
take the gradients from the back propop
and then we are using this DV which is
the first order gradient of the loss
function with respect to the weight
parameter and then multiply this with
the step size the EA and then we are
subtracting this from V which is the
current weight parameter in order to get
the new updated weight parameter
and the same we also do for our second
parameter which is the bias Factor so
one thing you can see here is that we
are using this step size the learning
rate which can be also considered a
separate topic we can go into details
behind this but for now uh think of the
learning rate as a step size which
decides how much of this size of the
step should be when we are performing
the updates because we know know exactly
how much the change there will be in the
L function when we make a certain change
in our parameters so we know the
gradient size and then it's up to us to
understand how much of this entire
change we need to apply so do we want to
make a big jump or we want to make a
smaller jumps when it comes to
iteratively improving the model
parameters if we take this learning rate
very large it means that we will apply a
bigger change which means the algorithm
will make a bigger step when it comes to
moving towards the global Optimum and
later on we will also see that it might
become problematic when we are making
too big of a jumps especially if those
are not accurate uh jumps so we need to
therefore ensure that we optimize this
learning parameter which is a hyper
parameter and we can tune this in order
to find the best learning rate that will
be minimizing the loss function and will
be optimizing our neural network and
when it comes to the gradient descent
the quality of this algorithm is very
high it is known as a good Optimizer
because it's using the entire training
data when performing the gradients so
performing the back propop and then
taking this in order to update the model
parameters and the gradients that we got
based on the entire training data is the
represents the true gradients so we are
not estimating it we are not making an
error but uh instead we are using the
entire training data when calculating
those gradients which means that we have
a good Optimizer that will be able to
make accurate steps towards finding the
global Optimum therefore GD is also
known as a good Optimizer and it's able
to find with higher likelihood the
global Optimum of the loss function so
the problem of the gradient descent is
that when it is using the entire
training data for every time updating
the model parameters it is just
sometimes computationally not visible or
super expensive because training a lot
of observations taking the entire
training data to perform Just One update
in your model parameters and every time
stor storing that large data into the
memory performing those iterations on
this large data it means that when you
have a very large data you using this
algorithm might take hours to optimize
in some cases even days or years when it
comes to using very large data or using
very complex data therefore GD is known
to be a good Optimizer but in some cases
it just not feasible to use it because
it's just not
efficient the next question is what is
the role of Optimizer in deep learning
so when it comes to to training a narrow
network uh we want to find what is the
set of hyperparameters and what is the
set of parameters that we can use as
part of our model that will end up
making the least amount of error because
when our algorithm is making the
smallest amount of error it means that
our predictions are most likely accurate
and when using it on a new unseen data
it will also perform in a much better
way so it means that we can rely on this
algor and we can apply it across
different applications without worrying
that it's making too much of an error so
in order to perform this optimization we
are making use of different optimization
algorithms creating in descent that we
just discussed is one of such algorithms
that is used in order to update the
model parameters in order to minimize
the amount of error that the model is
making in this case the amount of cost
or the loss that a Mot is making by
minimizing the loss function
so that is basically the primary goal of
the optimizers in not only deep learning
but also in general in machine learning
and in deep learning models so the idea
is that we will iteratively adjust the
model parameters in this case the weight
parameters and the bias parameters in
our model in order to end up with the
scenario and with the model where the uh
where the algorithm is making the
minimum amount of error or in some case
say it can be the objective function is
of the nature that should be maximized
it means that we will need to come up
with a set of parameters of the model
that will maximize that objective
function so depending on the type of
objective objective that you have as
part of your algorithm you will need to
then decide how your optimization
algorithm should be applied you will
need to minimize or you will need to
maximize your objective function so when
it comes to the optimization algorithms
we have the very original optimization
algorithms but there are also many other
variants of GD that have been developed
over the years in order to combat some
of the disadvantages that the GD has but
at the same time also to try to
replicate the benefits uh of the
gradient descent so the SGD is one
example of optimization algorithm beside
of GD uh there is this minib badge GD we
also have S GD with momentum when the
momentum was introduced to improve the
optimization algorithm such as HGD uh we
also have adaptive learning based type
of optimization techniques such as RMS
prop uh Adam and adamw also adagrad and
those are all different sorts of
optimization algorithms that are used in
deep learning in order to optimize the
algorithm so another aspect that we need
to keep in mind is that the goal of the
optimization algorithm is to iteratively
improve the model parameters such that
at the end we will end up finding the
global opum so during various type of
explanations when explaining the
variance of gradient descend and auto
optimizers I will be continuously making
use of this term Global Optimum so what
Global Optimum means is that it is the
actual minimum or actual maximum of the
objective function that we are using to
measure the error that the motor is
making because we can have a local
minimum or local maximum versus global
minimum or Global maximum what this
means is that when we have this area
consisting of many values that the error
can take in some cases when the
optimization is making those movements
in order to reach that minimum it might
confuse and end up discovering the local
minimum or local maximum Maxum instead
of finding the global minimum and Global
maximum what this means is that for some
area when the optimization algorithm is
moving in order to understand how it
should improve its direction to identify
that minimum in some cases it might
discover that well this is the minimum
that we are looking so the algorithm
will converge and it will decide that
this is the set of hyperparameters and
parameters that we need to use in order
to optimize our model but in the reality
it has confused the global minimum with
with the local minimum and it has
falsely declared that the algorithm has
converged and it has found the actual
minimum but it is actually the local
minimum not the global one and Global
one a global minimum it means that it is
actually the minimum cuz the local
minimum can seem as of it is the minimum
of the loss function but actually it is
just a volue that it is much smaller
than the surrounding values but it's
actually not the smallest one in the
entire set of values so ideally we want
to end up with a convergence and with a
state of the model where our all the
weights and the bias factors we found
they result in the actual minimum of the
loss function and not just the value
that for a certain set of Valu seems the
minimum therefore the goal is to
identify the global minimum and not the
local one next question is what is back
propagation and why it is important in
deep learning so back propagation is a
fundamental and essential part of
training of a neural network it helps
you learn from the errors that the model
is making in each iteration in order to
understand how the change in the certain
parameters of the model such as weight
factors and bias factors uh will result
in a change in the loss function so the
back propagation algorithm is the middle
part of the entire training process and
what I mean here is that we first
perform our forward path we go through
all this transformation when fetting the
uh input data into our Network and then
based on this Transformations we then
end up with the final output layer and
we then can perform our prediction so we
compute the Y hat once the Y hat is
computed we can then compute the loss
function or for that one specific
iteration after that forward pass once
we have the loss function then we can
understand how we need to change our
weights and our bias factors such that
we can make less errors that in the
current iteration the moral is making so
the errors the average errors that the
moral is making we are measuring it by
the loss function now then the next step
as part of this algorithm it is to
obtain
specific amount of change in the loss
function when we are making a small
change in the weights parameters and in
the bias parameters and this is what we
are also referring as gradients the
entire process of computing those
gradients is called back propagation so
back propagation is basically a fancy
way of referring to the process of
calculating the first order partial
derivative of the loss function with
respect to each of our modal parameters
including various weight parameters and
the bias parameters so this back
propagation is fundamental because it
helps the algorithm to understand how
much a change in L function we will
observe if we change each of those
different weight parameters because this
is the way that we need to uh Supply
this information to the optimization
algorithm such as G Adam in order for
the optimization algorithm to be able to
to update the model parameter so uh
basically the output of the back propop
is the input for the optimization
algorithm such as GD HGD adom Etc so if
we look at the specific example that we
have looked into as part of the previous
questions we saw this uh very simple
narrow Network where we had a small
amount of hidden layers and small amount
of hidden units and we had just couple
of input signals so as part of the
forward pass we then performed all the
Transformations we have activated the
neurons and then we end up with this y
hat which is the prediction of the
response variable so once we have the Y
hat then we also have cached our final
uh values for our Z scores so the Z
scores were equal to the X multip by the
weight parameters plus the bias
parameters so once we have this then we
can apply a various differentiation
rules specifically the change rule but
also we can make use of the
differentiation rule of the summations
and add one applied to the constant in
order to update the gradients of the L
function with respect to the activation
so the da and then we can use this in
order to obtain the gradients of the L
function with respect to the Z and then
we can make use of this da and then DZ
to obtain the gradients of the loss
function with respect to the weight so
that is DV and then finally in the
similar way we can make use of Da and DZ
in order to obtain the gradients of the
loss function with respect to the Beats
so our bias factors what is important
here is to keep in mind without going
too much into details of mathematical
derivations that in order to update uh
the model parameters we need to know the
uh gradients of the loss function with
respect to the weight parameter so DV as
well as the gradients of the bias
factors which is the first order partial
derivative of the loss function with
respect to the B so the bias factors but
then in order to compute the DV and the
DB mathematically we also need to First
compute the gradients of the activations
and the gradients of the the z s and the
reason for that is because the the
weight factors and the bias factors they
are part of the Z scor so we have this
chain of Transformations we applied
which means that when we are performing
differentiation we then also need to
perform this chain of differentiations
in order to be able to obtain the
gradients of the weights and gradients
of the Bas factors in the first place
which means that first we need to unpack
what is the gradients of the activations
then we need to understand what is the
gradients of the Z scor we need to then
use this applying the chain rule in
order to obtain this DV as you can see
here Z is equal to W mtip with the
activations a plus b to be more specific
the transpose of the weight Matrix
multiplied with the activations Matrix
then we are adding the bias vors which
forms our Zs and then to compute the
gradients of the loss function with
respect to the weight so DV we first
need to take the partial derivative of
the loss function J with respect to the
Z sores and then we need to
multiply with the partial derivative of
the Z scores with respect to the weight
Matrix in order to be able to compute
this partial derivative DV and then this
is simply equal to the DZ multiply by
the transpose of the activations Matrix
and something similar we are also
performing for obtaining the gradients
of the bias vectors I will not go too
much into detail of the mathematical
derivations I will not go too much into
details of the mathematical derivations
of this gradients cuz you will need to
dive deep into this various partial
derivatives we need to also refresh our
memory when it comes to using chain
rules the differentiation rules when it
comes to the sum of the values when it
comes to constant multiplied with the
target value and those are things that I
would definitely recommend you to
refresh when you are going through deep
learning topics but just to say in scope
of the interview question I just wanted
to share this just to refresh your
memory that um in every time when we are
trying to optimize the algorithm in
every step we are performing back
propagation which includes calculating
all these various gradients and in order
to compute the gradient with respect to
the weight and the gradient with respect
to the bias vectors we first also need
to calculate the gradients with respect
to activations and the gradients with
respect to the Z scores in order to then
use them to calculate the gradients of
the weights and then gradients of the
bias vectors and then to finalize this
the back propagation is simply this
process of computing the uh partial
derivatives of the loss function with
respect to the weights and with respect
to the bias factors in order to supply
them this as an input for our
optimization algorithm which is actually
our next question the next question is
how is back propagation different from
gradient descent so during your deep
learning interviews you might get a
question regarding the difference
between back propagation and gradient
descent this is usually a question a
tricky one to confuse you because
sometimes it's very intuitive to
describe the training process and to say
that we first perform our forward path
we then compute our loss function to see
how well the model is training and the
amount of air that is making on average
and then we compute the gradients to
understand how much we need to how much
of a change we have in the loss function
when we apply the uh change in various
uh parameters and then we use this in
order to uh Supply it to the backward
path to continuously then update the
model parameters up until the earlier
layers in order to end up with a model
that is performing better by coming from
the deeper layers to the earlier layers
so this sounds very intuitive and you
might be still you might be still be
asked a question but how is this then
different from the gradient descent what
is this different specifically when it
comes to B propagation and GD well the
answer to this question actually is very
simple one and this is just in my
opinion a question to trick the
interview but I would just say that the
back propagation is the actual process
of Computing the gradients to understand
how much a change in the L function is
there when we are changing the model
parameters and then the output of the
back propagation is simply used as an
input for the gradient descent or any
other optimization algorithm in order to
update the model parameters so the
gradient descent is simply using the
output of the back propagation as an
input because it's taking the computed
gradients from from the back prop as an
input in order to then update the model
parameters so the back propagation
happens in the middle once we end up
with our forward pass and then the back
propagation is done and then we are
performing our backward pass so we are
using the back prop and then we are
continuously iteratively updating our
model parameters from deeper layers to
the earlier layers and then this is what
is done by the optimization algorithm
the next question is describe what
Vanishing gradient problem is and it
impact on narrow networks so vention
gradients happens when the gradients of
a network so loss functions which
respect to the modal parameters such as
weights and the bias parameters they
become very small and in some cases they
become entirely close to zero which
means they start to vanish as they
propagate back through very deep layers
to the earlier layers and the result of
this Vanishing gradients is that the
network is no longer able to learn
dependencies in the data effectively and
the model is no longer able to update
the model effectively which means that
the algorithm will end up not being
optimized and we will end up with a
model that is unable and was not able to
learn the actual dependencies in the
data of course that's something that we
want to avoid and we want to have a
proper amount of gradients that we will
use as part of the optimization
algorithms like GD in order to obtain
the moral parameters and then do this
iteratively and continuously such that
we will end up minimizing our L function
and our model will be at a state that it
will provide highly accurate
predictions so how do we get this
Vanishing gradient problem and what is
the reason of that so as part of
training of a neural network we saw that
in each training iteration as part of
the gradient descent algorithm for
instance we would be using the entire
training data to train our Network and
then perform these different
Transformations from very earlier layers
to up until the last output layer to
take the activations and then
multiplying it with the weight Matrix
and then adding the bias parameters
comput the Z scores in this way and then
apply the activation function in order
to activate those neurons and then after
this is done in that specific hidden
layer the network is able to learn those
different dependencies in the D data and
then learn the structure and then move
on on to the next layer and then to the
next layer up until reaching the output
layer and then when we have our output
layer we then are able to calculate our
prediction so y hat and then we are able
to compare the Y hat to the true labels
or True Values and then understand what
is this loss function what is the
average error that the model is making
with this set of parameters and then we
are performing the back propagation to
comput gradients then supplying it to
the optimization algorithm in order to
update the model parameters and the way
the optimization algorithm is doing it
is uh opposite of the forward path so it
is Computing and taking the gradients
Computing the corresponding updates and
then updating the weights and the bias
factors from Deep layers to the earlier
layers and the problem with this is that
we are performing all these
Transformations and then we are
cumulatively every time time multiplying
those values what this means is that in
some cases especially when we have deep
Network when we have many hidden layers
by the time the network approaches from
Deep layers the middle layers and then
earlier layers this after this
multiplication of many of these weights
and this gradients start to become very
close to zero when the gradients become
very close to zero it means that we have
nothing than to update our weights and
update our bias parameters when we can
no longer update our weights in our
model it means that the network is no
longer able to properly learn especially
from the earlier layers when the
gradient is Vanishing and this is then
the problem because we want our model to
continuously learn and continuously
update those weights such that we will
end up with the best set of parameters
for the Ws and the bias factors in order
to uh minimize the loss function and
then provide highly accurate predictions
therefore ideally we want to ensure that
those gradients do not vanish so we
combat the vention gradient problem and
our network is able to properly learn
and understand this uh dependencies in
our data independent whether it's in the
Deep layers or in the earlier layers so
when it comes to description of this
problem try to focus on the weights
because that's the biggest challenge
when the gradients of the weight start
to vanish as especially for earlier
layers in a deep neural network and
that's something we want to avoid
because then the morel in case of
Vanishing gradients problem is no is not
able to effectively learn another
important thing that you can mention as
part of your answer is that there are
certain architectures that inherently
are subject to this problem and those
are especially the RNs or reur Naro
networks as well as lstms grus which are
all inherently deep in their nature
because unlike the original neural
networks like artificial neural networks
that have a single input layer they
provide the input and then the neurons
are being activated and they provide a
single output and the hidden layers they
are not interconnected so they are not
like the RNN that take the input and
then for each input they provide the
corresponding output and then this
hidden layer uh and then hid unit is
then being used as part of the next step
and the next step so they are not
sequential based like rnn's then they
are less likely to to be prone to this
Vanishing gradient problem than the RNs
or because rnms and other sequence type
of neural networks they are inherently
uh deep which means that they have this
multiple layers uh based on the amount
of time steps that they have which then
makes uh this algorithms more prone to
the vening gradient problem the next
question is what is the connection
between various activation functions and
the vening gradient problem so Vishing
gradient problem is highly related to
the choice of activation functions
because there are certain activation
functions that automatically result in
vention gradient problem because of
their inherit characteristics and there
are also activation functions which are
known to not cause the Vishing gradient
problem and of course we want to be
aware of such activation functions and
then not use them whenever we are aware
that there can be Vanishing gradient
problem so here I tend to make a
distinction between the sigmoid
activation function and the tank
activation function versus the reu so
rectifier linear unit and the Leaky relu
activation functions and the reason for
that is because of their inherit
property what we are calling saturation
what this means is that in case case of
sigmoid activation function for instance
when the activation is FZ is equal to 1
/ to 1 + e^ minus Z it means that
whenever the Z or the Z course is very
large negative number let's say minus
1000 then the corresponding activation
the F set will then be very close to
zero as you can see here which is
considered as a minimum for this sigmoid
function and then when the Z so the Z
score in this case from this graph the X
will be very large positive number so it
will be around 1,000 then the
corresponding function the activation
will be around one so very close to one
and as you can see at some point after
certain level of x uh for the positive
values independent how large this x will
be the corresponding activation will be
very close to one and at some point
there will not even be a change in this
area this is exactly what we are
referring as saturation which means that
when we have very large negative or very
large positive number then there will no
longer be any change in the
corresponding activation we will just
end up approaching the maximum or the
minimum of this function in this case
for very large positive ex's the Y will
be around one and for very large
negative numbers the corresponding activ
will be around zero therefore in case of
sigmoid activation function we are
saying that the sigmoid activation
function suffers from
saturation and it is prone to causing
the vanishing gradient problem so it
causes the gradients to vanish
especially when we have this very large
values as a z score so it can be large
positive or large negative and actually
the same holds for the tank activation
function because like like you can see
here Tang activation function like
sigmoid activation function is this
s-shaped activation function and like
sigmoid function the tank also suffers
from saturation and in here you can see
that when we have X which is very large
positive number let's say 1,000 then the
corresponding activation will be around
one the same will hold if we change this
X and we make it 2,000 or 3,000 so so
independent how much we will increase
this large number for X the
corresponding activation will be the
same it will be close to one which is
the maximum of this function and then
the same holds for the very large
negative numbers for this activation
function so let's say the x is around-
1,000 then the corresponding activation
will be around minus1 but the same holds
also when the X will be around - 2000 or
- 10K so this means that in case of tank
activation function as in case of sigo
activation function when we have very
large positive or very large negative
values and we want to see how much we
can activate them using this activation
function then the corresponding
activation value is around the extreme
of this function so minus one and one in
case of tank function and the zero and
one in case of sigmoid activation
function so therefore like in case of
sigmoid activation function we are
saying that tank activation function
suffers from saturation and this means
that tank activation function inherently
causes the vanishing gradient problem
because it's causing the gradients to
vanish and that's something that we want
to avoid so one thing that we can keep
in mind is that the sigmoid activation
function and Tang activation functions
are great when it comes to the output
layer because they have this nice
properties in transforming the values
between certain C ranges like in case of
sigmoid function it transforms the
values any values between Z and one
which is great when we want to have an
output in the form of probabilities
great for classification type of
problems but when it comes to using this
activation functions for hidden layers
that's something that we want to avoid
so my suggestion would be to use sigmoid
activation function or hyperbolic tank
activation function for your output
layers but then do not use it for your
hidden layers because they are prone to
Vanishing gradient problem the next set
of activation functions that we will
discuss today are the rectifier linear
unit and the Leaky Rel so leaky
rectifier linear unit unlike the sigmoid
activation function and the Tang
activation function reu or Liu they both
do not suffer from saturation this means
that they are then no longer causing the
vening gradient problem and they are
great for using it as part of the Hidden
layer
it you can see that the for the cases
when the we take very large positive X
then the corresponding activations will
change and when we go from let's say
1,000 to 2,000 from 2,000 till 10K we
will have the corresponding activation
values also change a lot which means
that the activation function will not
result in the gradients coming very
close to zero which is what we are
describing as a Vishing gradients so as
part of this REO will not be causing the
vening gradient problem which is
something that is great especially when
we are using them as part of our hidden
layers the same also holds for the Le
which you can see here because the two
are very similar to each other and with
only difference that Liu does consider
activating at some extent the negative
neurons which means that when ex is
negative value so for from minus
infinity to 0 you can see that the
corresponding activations are not zero
but they are equal to
0.01 so this means that unlike the
sigmoid and tank activation function
those two are not suffering from
saturation so they activation values
will change and will not be close to the
same extreme of the function uh when we
make very when we provide as an input
very large positive or very large
negative vales which means that they are
ideal for using as part of the Hidden
layers such that the network can
continuously effectively learn those
hidden dependencies in the data
therefore we are saying use reu and
leaky reu as part of your hidden layers
to activate those neurons and whenever
you approach this output layer for the
output layer use the sigmoid function or
the Hang activation function the next
question is there is a neuron in the
hidden layer that always results results
in a large error in back propagation and
what could be the reason for that so
there can be many reasons that can
result in this specific neuron or some
of the neurons to consistently result in
large error as part of the back
propagation in the na Network so the
first reason could be poor
initialization of the weights and what
this means is that in the very beginning
when we are starting the training
process we need to initialize the weight
PR
and the bias parameters such that the
network can uh take this initial values
and then perform the forward pass
compute the loss and then use this as an
input for the optimization algorithm
like GD SGD in order to then update
those weight parameters
iteratively but if we do this
initialization of the we weights not in
a proper way which means that we are not
using the right distribution to random
from it to randomly sample from from it
or we are just providing a wrong or not
proper value to this weight and bias
parameters it means that this will right
from the beginning skew off the learning
process for those specific neurons and
if we right from the beginning perform
the learning process in an improper way
and we are sking those learning
processes in every iteration this means
that the next iteration that will be
based in the first iteration that
started wrongly from the first pass it
will also be done in the wrong way and
then the next time and then next time
this process will continue to result
every time in an improper learning and
in the large error as part of the
calculation of the loss and then back
propagation and another reason for this
can be the V Vanishing or the exploding
gradients so if the gradients become
very small uh and the weight of the
neurons especially in deep network no
longer start to update those different
parameters this means that uh we can
persistently make those large errors in
specific Neons because we are no longer
able to effectively learn those
dependencies in the model and uh that
specific name will not be correctly
activated and will not be the
corresponding weights will not be
updated in order to improve the accuracy
of the predictions for those specific
neurons and of course the same holds for
the opposite problem which is the
exploding gradient problem if we are
making too much of an updates and right
and the neurons are not being properly
activated the corresponding weights are
not being properly updated this means
that we will be consistently making
those large errors for those Neons
another reason for this can be
inadequate learning rate which means
that if we have too high learning rate
or too small learning rate we might be
overshooting the optimal values during
the training or undershooting so
insufficiently updating those weight
parameters and those bias parameters and
this means that we will then
continuously make large errors for those
specific Neons therefore it's really
important to optimize these hyper
parameters in our model such that the
model can make consistent updates and
consistently improve the model
parameters which means also uh improve
the learning process another reason can
be improper activation function because
activation functions can significantly
impact the learning process the way we
activate our neurons will be a defining
factor for the neuron Network to
properly learn those dependencies in
data and then understand how the weight
parameters and the parameters need to
updated such then the such that the
learning will be optimized the next
question is what do understand by a
computation graph so computational graph
is a way to visualize complex operations
that we are using as part of uh training
models as part of various type of
optimization processes and it's a great
way to Showcase all the steps that we
are taking when going from very simple
variables or objects till applying
various Transformations and then getting
to the very complex functions so one way
that we are using comp ational graphs
are when we are visualizing the neural
networks so we saw this a very basic
representation and a basic neural
network in the earlier interview
questions and this one is a vivid
example of applying computational graph
in here you can see that we are using
the the not and the edges in order to
describe the computational graph and the
in the computational graph we usually
have the nodes representing objects or
variables and then the edges usually
represent the type of operations or
Transformations that we are applying to
those objects or variables in this case
you can see that we have input signals
X1 X2 X3 which are simply the variables
those are the nodes at the initial layer
and then we are showcasing that we are
applying those edges this arrows that go
onto our first hidden layer in this
hidden layer you can see that we have
the Z scores pair hidden unit and then
we have the corresponding Activation so
Z1 A1 corresponding to the first hidden
layers first hidden unit and then we
have the Z2 A2 and a Z3 A3 Z4 A4 because
we have four different hidden unit as
part of our single hidden layer then we
apply another
transformation uh when we go from the
first hidden layer to the uh to to the
output layer what you can see here is
that we have this arrows that showcase
how we go from X1 X2 X3 so our input
data uh to the Z scores and then we
apply the activation on the Z scores to
compute our activation scores and then
we use this activation scores from the
final layer in order to go onto our uh
predictions which is the Y hat you can
see here that we are using this final
output layer to compute the Y hat
and uh this is something that we are
doing to visualize this process of
computing first the Z scores based on
the XI the input data multiplied with
the transpose of the weight Matrix W
plus b so this set the observation layer
observation level and then the uh y I
had is then simply equal to AI equal to
Sigma zi and what we are doing here is
that we are uh Computing the Z scores
and then after Z scores we are applying
this Sigma function which is the
activation function that we are getting
and then after the activation function
is applied on the Z scores we are then
Computing and getting the activation
scores and then using this activation
scores to compute our Yi head and then
once we have our Yi head which is our
prediction then we are comparing it to
the True Values so the y i and then we
are Computing our loss so the amount of
airor that the motor is making so you
can see what are those steps that we are
making and when we have more hidden
layers not just one but let's say three
four or billions of those layers then we
will end up having a very hard time
understanding those different steps let
alone to visualize it or to Showcase how
many layers we have and each time using
different IND is each time performing
the same
Transformations from input data to Z
scor and then to activation function for
after activation function we get the
activation scores you get the idea so
it's then much easier to Showcase all
these calculations using this
computational graph so basically we
instead of using all these
Transformations these matrices that can
be hard to understand uh we are using
the computational graph to simplify the
process and to visualize it to Showcase
how we go from the input variables um
and then we apply all these
Transformations and then we end up with
the
predictions and then this computational
graph can be made bit more difficult by
also showcasing the the other side of
the story so getting the uh predictions
and then applying back propagation and
then from back propagation to the actual
gradiate calculations and then the
updates of the parameters but then just
for Simplicity I thought I will just use
this simple neural network to Showcase
this but of course the idea behind
computational graph is not just to
Showcase a forward path but also to
showcase the entire network including
the back propagation so calculation of
the gradient what is gradient clipping
and their impact on Naro Network so we
just saw the residual connections and we
saw that residual connections especially
for deep neural network and specifically
for the cases like RNN lstms when we
have the sequential nature with too many
layers uh we can have this Vanishing
gradient problem and residual
connections can help to solve this
problem now gradient clipping is solving
the opposite problem so it's solving the
exploring gradient problem whenever we
have certain deep naral networks like
RNN lstms because we are each time using
these Transformations and we are using a
cumulative nature and multiplying all
these weights towards each other through
this process and we are using the
previous hidden state to update the the
new hidden state so next hidden State
and next one it also means that when we
are going through these layers during
the uh optimization process after back
propop is done we need to perform all
this Transformations and by the time we
come through the earlier layers it can
be that we have exploding gradients so
the gradients become so large that it
starts to impact the entire performance
of the model we are starting to make two
big over jumps and the updates that we
are starting to get and optimization
process is starting to make too much of
this oscilations towards different
directions so we are seeing this tic
Behavior as part of our optimization
process and that's definitely not
something that we want to have because
exploring great Radiance means that we
have unstable naral network and uh this
also means that the update of the
weights will be too large and this will
then result in not well performing and
not properly trained neural network now
to avoid all these problems the way we
can solve this exploding gradient uh
problem is by using the uh gradient
clipping what gradient clipping does is
that it basically Clips the gradients at
a certain level so there is a threshold
which is the parameter that we are using
for gradient clipping and whenever the
gradient becomes too large so higher
than the threshold then we will be
clipping that gradient to ensure that
this gradient is not too large and we
are not updating our weight parameters
or bios sectors too much so in this way
what we are doing is that we are kind of
stabilizing our neural network which is
especially important for architectures
like lstms RNN grus uh which have this
sequential nature of the data with too
many layers and uh in this way we will
ensure that we do not have this ertic
jumps in our naral Network optimization
process and we will end up with a stable
Network that is able to properly learn
the
interdependencies
the next question is what is cross
entropy and why it is preferred as a
cost function for multiclass
classification type of problems so cross
entropy which is also known as log loss
it measures the performance of a
classification model that has an output
in the terms of probabilities which are
values between zero and one so whenever
you are dealing with classification type
of problem let's say you want to
classify whether an image is of a cat or
a dog or and the house can be classified
as a old house versus a new house in all
those cases when you have these labels
and you want the morel to provide a
probability uh to each of those classes
per observation such that you will have
as an output of your model that the
house a has 50% probability of being
classified as new 50% probability of
being class ified as old or the cat has
70% probability of U uh being a cat
image or this image has 30% probability
of of being a dog image in all those
cases when you are dealing with this
type of problems you can apply the cross
entropy as a loss function and the cross
entropy is measured as this negative of
the sum of the Y log p + 1 - Y and then
log 1 minus P where Y is the actual
label so in binary classification this
can be for instance one and zero and
then p is the predicted probability so
in this case the P will be then the
value between 0 and one and then the Y
is the corresponding label so let's say
a label zero when you are dealing with
cat image and label one when you are
dealing with a dog image and the
mathematical explanation behind this
formula is out of the scope of this
question so I will not going into that
details but if you are interested in
that make sure to check out the logistic
regression model this is part of my
machine learning fundamentals handbook
which you can check out and this one
includes also logistic regression which
explains step by step how we end up with
this log likelihood function and how
then we go from the products to
summations after applying the
logarithmic function so we get the log
ODS and then we multiply it with the
minus because this is the uh negative of
the likelihood function given that we
want to ideally minimize the loss
function and this is the opposite of the
likelihood function um and in this case
what the showcases is that we will end
up getting a volue that tells how well
the model is performing in terms of
classification so the cross entropy then
will tell us whether the model is doing
a good job in terms of classifying the
observation to a certain class the next
question is what kind of loss function
we can apply when we are dealing with
multiclass
classification so in this case when
dealing with multiclass classification
we can use the multiclass crow entropy
which is often referred as a softmax
function so softmax loss function it's a
great way to measure the performance of
a model that wants to classify
observation to one of the multiple
classes which means that we are no
longer dealing with binary
classification but we are dealing with
multic class
classification so one example of such
case is when we want to classify an
image to be from Summer theme to be from
Spring theme or from winter theme given
that we have three different possible
classes we are no longer dealing with
binary classification but we are dealing
with multiclass classification which
means that that we also need to have a
proper way to measure the performance of
the model that will do this
classification and soft Max is doing
exactly this so instead of getting the
pair observation two different values
which will say what is the probability
of that observation belonging to class
one or class two instead we will have a
larger Vector pair observation depending
on the number of classes you will be
having in this specific example we will
end up having three different values so
one vector with three different entries
per observation saying what is the
probability that this picture is from
Winter seene what is the probability of
this observation coming from Summer
theme and the third one what is the OBS
what is the probability that the
observation comes from a spring theme in
this way we will then have all the
classes with the corresponding
probabilities so as in case of the Cross
entropy also in case of the soft Max
when we are when we have a small value
for the softmax it means that the model
is performing a good job in terms of
classifying observations to different
classes and we have well separated
classes and one thing to keep in mind
when we are comparing cross entropy and
multi class cross entropy or the softmax
is that we are usually using this
whenever we have more than two classes
and you might recall from the uh
Transformer um model introduction from
the paper tension is all you need that
as part of this architecture of
Transformers a soft Max layer is also
applied um as part of the multiclass
classification so when we are uh
Computing our activation course and also
at the end when we want to transform our
output to a values that make sense and
to measure the performance of the
Transformer the Transformer the next
question is what is a s GD and why it is
used in training naral networks so SGD
is like GD an optimization algorithm
that is used in deep learning in order
to optimize the performance of a deep
learning model and to find a set of
model parameters that will minimize the
loss function by iteratively improving
the parameters of the model including
the weight parameters and the bias
parameters so the SGD the way it
performs the update of model parameters
is by using a randomly selected single
or just few training observations so
unlike the GD which was using the entire
training data to update the model
parameters in one iteration in case of
SGD the SGD is using just single uh
randomly selected training observation
to perform the update so what this
basically means is that instead of using
the entire training data for each up dat
SGD is making those updates in the model
parameters per training observation and
there is also an importance of this
random component so the stochastic
element in this algorithm hence also the
name stochastic gradient decent because
SGD is randomly sampling from training
observations a single or just couple of
training data points and then using that
it performs the forward path so it
computes the Z scores and then computes
the activation scores after applying
activation function then reaches the end
of the forward path and the network
computes the output so the Y hat and
then computes the loss and then we
perform the back prop only on those few
data points um and then we are getting
the gradients which are then no longer
the exact gradient so in SGD given that
we are using only a randomly Selected
Few data point or a single data point
instead of having the actual gradients
we are estimating those true gradients
because the true gradients are based on
the entire training data and in SGD for
this optimization we are using only few
data points what this means is that we
are getting an imperfect estimate of
those gradients as part of the back
propagation which means that the
gradients will contain this noise and
the result result of this is that we are
making the optimization process much
more efficient because we are making
those uh uh parameter updates very
quickly based on pass by using only a
few data points U and training a Neal
Network on just a few data points is
much faster uh and easier than using an
entire training data for a single update
but this comes at the cost of the
quality of the SGD because when we are
using only a few data points to train
the model and then compute gradients
which are the estimate of the true
gradients then this gradients will be
very noisy they will be imperfect and
most likely far off from the actual
gradients which also means that uh we
will make a less accurate update to our
model parameters and this means that
every time when the optimization
algorithm is trying to find that Global
Optimum and make those movements per
each r
to move one step closer towards that
Optimum most of the time it will end up
making wrong decisions and will pick the
wrong direction given that the gradient
is the source of that choice of what
direction it needs to take and every
time it will make those uh oscilations
those movements which will be very
erratic and it will end up most of the
time discovering the Lo opum instead of
the global opum because every time when
it's using just very small part of the
training data it's estimating the
gradients which are noisy which means
that the direction it will take will
most likely be also a wrong one and when
you make those wrong directions and
wrong moves every time you will start to
ciliate and this is exactly what HD is
doing it's making those wrong decision
Choice when it comes to direction of the
optimization and it will end up
discovering a local optim instead of the
global one and therefore the HGD is also
known to be a bad Optimizer it is
efficient it is great in terms of
convergence time in terms of the memory
usage CU storing moral and that is based
on a very small data and storing that
small data into the memory is not
computationally heavy and memory heavy
but this comes at the cost of this
quality of the Optimizer and in the
upcoming interview questions we will
learn how we can adjust this SGD
algorithm in order to improve the
quality of this optimization technique
the next question is why does sastic
gradient Des sense or the SGD oate
towards local minimum so there are a few
reasons why this oscilation happens but
first let's discuss what oscilation is
so oscilation is the movement that we
have when we're trying trying to find
the global Optimum so uh whenever we are
trying to optimize the algorithm by
using an optimization method like GD SGD
RMS probe Adam we are trying to minimize
the loss function and ideally we want to
change iteratively our model parameters
so much that we will end up with the set
of parameters resulting in the minimum
so Global minimum of the loss function
not just local minimum but the global
one and the difference between the two
is that the local minimum might appear
as of it's the minimum of the loss
function but it holds only for a certain
area when we are looking at this
optimization process whereas the global
Optimum is really the mean the real
minimum of the loss function and that's
exactly uh that we are trying to chase
when we have too much oscilations which
means too much movements when we are
trying to find the direction towards the
global Optimum then this might become
problematic because we then are making
too many movements every time and if we
are making those movements that are
opposite or they are towards the wrong
direction then this will end up
resulting in discovering local opum
instead of global opum something that we
are trying to avoid and the oscilations
happen much more often in the SGD
compared to GD because in case of GD we
are using the entire training data uh in
order to compute the gradient so the
partial derivative of the loss function
with respect to the parameters of the
model whereas in case of SGD we learned
that we are using just randomly SLE
single or few training data points in
order to update the gradients and to use
these gradients to update the model
parameters this then for SGD results in
having too many of this oscilation
because the the random subsets that we
are using they are much smaller than
training data they do not contain all
the information in training data and
this means that the gradients that we
are calculating in each step when we are
using entirely different and very small
data can defer significantly one time we
uh can have One Direction the other time
an entirely uh different direction uh
for our movement in our optimization
process and uh this huge difference
there's variability in the direction
because of the huge difference in the
gradients can result in too often of
this oscilation so too many of uh
bouncing around towards the area to find
the right direction towards the global
Optimum in this case the minimum of the
loss function so that's the first reason
the random subsets the second reason why
in HGD we have too many of those
oscilations those movements
uh is the step size so step size the
learning rate can Define how much we
need to update the the weights and or
the bias parameters and the magnitude of
this updates is determined by this
learning rate which then also plays a
role how many of this how different this
movements will be and how large uh the
the jumps will be when we are looking at
the
oscilations so the the third reason why
the SGD will suffer from too many of
oscilations which is a bad thing because
it will result in finding a local
Optimum instead of the global Optimum
too many times is the imperfect estimate
so when we are Computing the gradients
of the loss function with respect to the
weight parameters or the bias factors
then if this is done on a small sample
of the training data then the gradients
will be noisy whereas if we were to use
the entire training data that contains
all all the information about the
relationships between the features and
just in general in the data then the
gradients will be much less noisy they
will be much more accurate therefore
because we are using this the gradients
of based on small data as estimate of
the actual gradients which is based on
the entire training data this introduces
a noise so imperfection when it comes to
estimating this true gradient and this
imperfection can result in updates that
do not always Point directly towards the
global opum and this will then cause
this oscilations in the
HGD so at higher level I would say that
there are three reasons why HGD will
have too many of these oscilations the
first one is the random subsets the
second one is the step size and the
third one is definitely the imperfect
estimate of the
gradients the next next question is how
is GD different from HGD so what is the
difference between the gradient descent
and the stochastic gradient descent so
by now given that we have gone too much
into details of HGD I will just give you
a higher level summary of the
differences of the two so for this
question I would answer by making use of
four different factors that CA a
difference between the GD and HGD so the
first factor is the data usage the
second one is the update frequency the
third one is the computational
efficiency and the fourth one is the
convergence pattern so let's go into one
of this into each of these factors one
by one so gradient descent uses the
entire training data when uh training
the model and Computing the gradients
and using this gradients as part of back
propagation process to update the model
parameters however SGD unlike GD is not
using the entire training data when
performing the training process and
updating the model parameters in one go
instead what SGD does is that it uses
just a randomly sample single or just
two training data points when performing
the training and when using the
gradients based on the Su points in
order to update the model parameters so
that's the data usage and the amount of
data that SGD is using versus the GD so
the second difference is the update
frequency so given that GD updates the
model parameters based on the entire
training data every time it makes much
less of this updates compared to the HGD
because HGD then very frequently every
time for this single data point or just
few training data points it updates the
model parameters unlike the GD that has
to use the entire training data for just
one single set of update so this causes
then SGD to make those update much more
frequently uh when using just a very
small data so that's about the
difference in terms of update frequency
then another difference is the
computational efficiency so GD is less
computationally efficient than HGD
because GD has to use this entire
training data uh make the computation so
back propagation and then update the
model parameters based on this entire
training data which can be
computationally heavy especially if you
are dealing with a very large data and
very complex data and unlike GD SGD is
much more efficient and very fast
because it's using a very small amount
of data to perform the updates which
means that it is it requires less amount
of memory to sort data it uses small
data and it will then take much less
amount of time to find a global optim or
at least it thinks that it finds the
global opum so the convergence is much
faster in case of SGD compared to GD
which makes it much more efficient than
the GD then the final factor that I
would mention as part of this question
is the converence pattern so GD is known
to be smoother and of higher quality as
an optimization algorithm than SGD SGD
is known to be a bed Optimizer and the
reason for this is because that the
efficiency of HGD comes at a cost of the
quality of it of finding the global
Optimum so SGD makes all the all this
oscilation
given that it's using a very small part
of the training data when estimating the
true gradients and unlike SGD GD is
using the entire training data so it
doesn't need to estimate the gradients
it's able to determine the exact
gradients and this causes a lot of
oscilations Ina in case of SGD and in
case of GD we don't need to make all
these oscilations so the amount of
movements that the algorithm is making
is much smaller and that's why it takes
much less amount of time for HG to find
the global optim but unfortunately most
of the time it confuses the global optim
with the local opum so SGD ends up
making this many movements and it end up
discovering the local opum and confuses
it with the global opum which is of
course not desirable because we would
like to have the actual Global opum so
the set of parameters that will actually
minimize and find the minimum value of
the loss function and SGD is the
opposite because it's using the true
gradients and it is most of the time
able to identify the true Global optim
so the next question is how can we use
optimization methods like GD uh but in a
more improved way so how we can improve
the GD and what is the role of the
momentum term so whenever you hear
momentum and then GD uh try to
automatically focus on the HGD with
momentum because SGD with momentum is
basically Al the improved version of HGD
and as far as you know the difference
between HGD and GD it will be much
easier for you to explain what is the
HGD with
momentum so uh we just discussed that
the HD suffers from oscilation so too
many of those movements and a lot of
time because we are using a small amount
of training data to estimate the true
gradients this will result in having
entirely different gradients and too
much of the different sorts of updates
in the weights and of course that's
something that we want to avoid because
we saw and we explained that too many of
those movements will end up causing the
optimization algorithm to mistakenly
confuse uh the global opum and local
opum so it will pick the local opum
think that it's a global opum but it's
not the case so to solve this problem
and to improve the uh SGD algorithm
while taking into to account that SGD in
many aspects is much more much better
than the GD we came up with this SGD
with momentum algorithm where HGD with
momentum will take basically the
benefits of the HGD and then it will
also try to address the biggest
disadvantage of HGD which is this too
many of these
oscilations and the way SGD with
momentum does is that it uses this
momentum and it introduces this idea of
momentum so momentum is basically a way
to find and put the optimization
algorithm towards better Direction and
reduce the amount of oscilations so the
amount of all this random movements and
the way that it does is that it tries to
add a fraction of this previous updates
that we made on the motor parameters
which then we assume will be a good
indication of the more accurate
Direction in this specific time step so
imagine that we are at time time step T
and we need to make the update then uh
the what momentum does is that uh it
looks at all the previous updates and
uses the more recent updates more
heavily and says that the more recent
updates most likely uh will be better
representation of the direction that we
need to take versus the very old updates
and this updates in the optimization
process these very recent ones when we
take them into account then we can have
a better uh a better way of and more
accurate way of updating the moral
parameters so let's look into
mathematical representation just for a
quick refreshment so what the SGD with
momentum tries to do is to accelerate
this conversion process and instead of
having too many of the movements towards
the different direction and having two
different ofen gradients and updates it
tries to stabilize this process and have
more constant updates and in here you
can see that as part of the momentum we
are obtaining this momentum term which
is equal to VT +1 for the update at the
time step of t+1 what it does is that it
takes this this gamma multiplies it by
VT plus the learning rate ITA and then
the gradient where you can see that this
inflated triangle and then underneath
the Theta and then J Theta T simply
means the gradient of the loss function
with respect to the parameter TAA and
what what is basically doing is that it
says we are Computing this momentum term
for the time step of t+ one which is
based on the previous updates uh through
this term GMA multip by VT plus the the
common term that we saw before for the
SGD and for GD which is basically uh
using this ITA learning rate multiplied
by the first order partial derivative of
the loss function with respect to the
parameter TAA so we then are using this
momentum term to Simply subtract it from
our current parameter TAA T in order to
uptain and the new version so the
updated version which is TAA t + one
where TAA is simply the model parameter
so in this way what we are doing is that
we are performing more the updates in
more consistent way so we are
introducing consistency into the
direction by waiting the recent
adjustments more heavily and it builds
up the momentum hence the name moment
momentum so the momentum builds up this
speed towards the direction of the
global opum in more consistent gradients
enhancing the uh movement towards This
Global Optimum so the global minimum of
the loss function and this then on its
turn will improve of course the quality
of the optimization algorithm and we
will end up discovering the global
Optimum rather than local Optimum so to
summarize what this SGD with momentum
does is that it basically takes the HGD
algorithm so it again uses a small
training data when performing the model
parameter updates but unlike the SGD
what SGD with momentum does is that it
tries to replicate the gd's quality when
it comes to the finding the actual
Global optim and the way it does that is
by introducing this momentum term which
helps also to reduce consistency in the
updates and to reduce the oscilations
the algorithm is making by having much
more smoother path towards discovering
the actual Global Optimum of the L
function the next question is compare
badge gradient descent to mini badge
gradient descent and to stochastic
gradient descent so here we have three
different versions of the gradient
descent algorithm the uh traditional
badge gradient descent uh often referred
as GT simply uh the second algorithm is
the mini badge gradient descent and the
third algorithm is the SGD or the
stochastic gradient descent so the three
algorithm are algorithms are very close
to each other they do differ in terms of
their efficiency and the amount of data
that they are using when performing each
of this model training and the model
parameters update so let's go through
them one by one so the bch gradient
descent this is the orig
GD uh this method involves the
traditional approach of using the entire
training data for each iteration when
Computing the gradients so doing the
back prop and then taking this gradients
as an input for the optimization
algorithm to perform a single update for
these model parameters then on to the
next iteration when again using the
entire training data to compute the
gradients and to update the model
parameters so here for the badge
gradient descent we are we are not
estimating the true gradients but we are
actually Computing the gradients because
we have the entire training data now B
gradient descent thanks to this quality
of using the entire training data uh has
a very high quality so it's very stable
it's able to identify the actual Global
Optimum however this comes at a cost of
efficiency because the bch gradient
descent uses the entire training data it
needs to every time put this entire
training data into the memory and it is
very slow when it comes to per
performing the optimization especially
when dealing with large and complex data
sets now next we have the Other Extreme
of the bch gradient descent which is SGD
so SGD unlike the GD and we saw this
previously when discussing the previous
intrview questions that SGD is using uh
stochastically so randomly sampled
single or just few training observations
in order to perform the training so
Computing the gradients Performing the
backrop and then using optimization to
update the model parameters in each
iteration which means that we actually
we do not compute the actual gradients
but we actually are estimating the true
gradients because we are using just a
small part of the training data so uh
this of course comes at a cost of the
quality of the algorithm although it's
efficient to use only small sample uh
from the training data when doing the
back prop the training we need you don't
need to store
uh the entire training data into the
memory but just a very small portion of
it and we perform the model updates
quickly but then uh we find the
so-called Optimum much quicker compared
to the GD but this comes at a cost of
the quality of the algorithm because
then it starts to make too many of these
oscilations due to this noisy gradients
which then ends up confusing the global
opum with the local opum and then
finally we have our third optimization
algorithm uh which is the mini badge
gradient descent and this mini badge
gradient descent is basically the Silver
Lining between the badge gradient
descent and the original HGD so sastic
gradient descent and the way mini badge
works is that it tries to strike this
balance between the traditional GD and
the SGD it tries to take the advantages
of the SGD when it comes to uh the
efficiency and combine it with the
advance of GD when it comes to stability
and consistency of the updates and
finding the actual Global Optimum and
the way that it does that is by randomly
sampling the training observations into
two batches where the batch is much
bigger compared to SGD and it then uses
this smaller portions of training data
in each iteration to to do the back
propop and then to update the moral
parameters so think of this like the
kfold cross validation when we are
sampling our training data into this K
different folds in this case batches and
then we are using this in order to train
the model and then in case of naral
networks to use the mini mini badge
gradient descent to update the model
parameters such as weights and bias
vectors so the tree have have a lot of
similarities but they also have
differences and in this interview
question your interview is trying to
test whether do you understand the
benefits of one and two and what is the
purpose of having mini badge grade in
descent so the next question is how to
decide the badge size in a deep learning
considering both twoo small and twoo
large sizes this question is a very
important question where the interviewer
is trying to test whether you understand
what is the impact of the badge size uh
on your entire algorithm the quality of
it so here your interviewer wants to
know your understanding of the best size
impact on the gradient noise on the bias
of your model on the variance of the
model on the generalization of the model
uh the convergence of the model the
efficiency especially the memory usage
so uh we just discussed and compared the
traditional badge gradient descent to
the mini badge gradient descent and to
the HGD and here we have already touched
on this idea of using uh very large
training data using small part of the
training data like mini batches versus
using even smaller like a single or very
few observations randomly sampled from
training data and this question is
exactly related to that so let's say we
have this mini badge gradient descent
and we want to understand what is this
badge size that we need to use what are
the amount of observations that we need
to put in single batch when performing
the uh training process performing the
back propop and then updating the model
parameters in each
iteration so let's compare the uh small
bed size versus large bed size uh with
respect to all these factors that I just
mentioned so uh when it comes to the
small bed sizes which means that let's
say we have uh two up to 32 as the bed
size so we have one till 32 observations
uh that have that are in our batch so in
this case the uh gradient noise will be
of course very high and the reason for
that is because we are using a very
small part of the training data when
estimating the gradients of our model
the true gradients and this of course
means that this estimate will Pro most
likely not be the proper estimate for
the true gradient because we are using
just a very small part of the training
data and this then introduces a lot of
noise into our model versus when we have
a large bed size then the gradient noise
will be lower because we are using a
larger training part uh training data
part
when performing the estimation of the
true gradient then we have the
convergence so when it comes to the
small bed sizes the convergence tends to
tends to be the quality of the
convergence tends to be worse because
it's like the SGD it tends to make all
of these oscilations and though the
convergence will be Speedy so it will be
quick but it will most likely discover
the local optim versus the global optim
while when we have large bed sites then
the AL it will often converge to sharper
minimum so the the actual Global Optimum
and the process might take slower but
the quality will be higher then we have
the generalization Factor uh
generalization basically refers to the
idea of overfitting how how much the
model is actually memorizing the
training data versus being able to
perform equally well on the Unseen data
now whenever we are using the entire
training data which a lot of times will
contain noise then the model by every
time using this large portion or the
entire training data when training the
model it will be more likely to use this
noise in order to obtain gradients and
then perform modal parameter updates
what this basically means is that for
these large bed sizes then the
generalization will be potentially worse
because the model will be memorizing the
training data it will be it will most
likely uh catch this noise as a normal
points and it will be much more focused
on the training data uh whereas when we
have a smaller bed size then we are
randomly selecting a much smaller
portion of the training data and the
likelihood of having a noise in that
small part of the training data in the
small batch is lower which means that
the like lihood of the morel following
this noise and overfitting and
Performing very worse on the Unseen new
training data a new test data uh is
lower so just to summarize when it comes
to generalization because it's really
important when we have small bed size
then we have potentially better
generalizing model because we will then
using a small portion of the training
data and the model will be less inclined
to memorize the training data and it
will perform uh equally well on the new
unseen data versus the large B size
which will intend and will have higher
likelihood of following the noise in the
data and then not generalizing well on
the Unseen data then we have the bias so
small bad size case then the bias will
be potentially lower because the model
will be less likely to overfit to the
training pattern whenever we have a
moral overfitting then the bias will be
higher if we have lower chance for
overfitting then the bias will be lower
this also means that generalization and
the bias are very much related as we
also know in the traditional machine
learning and the the opposite holds for
the large bad size because for the large
bed size we saw that it generalizes
worse uh at the lesser extent which also
means that the bias will most likely be
higher in case of large B size so uh
when it comes to the variance then in
case of small small bed size the
variance is higher because we are every
time using a different part of the
training data and small part so there
will be much more of the oscilations and
the exploration when it comes to finding
the global Optimum whereas in case of
larger bad size then we have a variance
which is much lower because we are
making less explorations to find the
solution of the optimization process
then we have the computational cost and
the memory usage for large bed sizes
when we have large amount of data then
we will be storing much more data into
the memory it also means that the
convergence will be slower and the
computational cost will be higher and
the smaller is the bed size the lower is
computational cost and the lower is the
memory usage so the next question is how
does the bedge size impact the
performance of a deep learning model so
bed size which is a number of training
samples that we use pair iteration when
performing the training of the model
Computing the gradients as part of back
propop and then updating our model
parameters per iteration uh plays a
significant role in the performance and
the final outcome of the deep learning
model there are few things that I would
advise to mention as part of your
interview answer to this question and
the first one is definitely the training
time and here it's important to to anal
ize this with respect to the training
time per iteration training time per
Epoch and the overall training time
because the two the Tre are actually
very much different when we compare the
bed size and here we would like to
compare the small badge versus the large
badge so when it comes to this smaller
badge sizes which means that we are
using smaller portion of the training
data per iteration to compute the
gradients and to perform the updates
this means that per Epoch so it means
when we want to pass the entire training
data which is one Epoch it means that we
need to have many of these iterations
because per iteration we need to have we
we just use a small portion of the
training data and the smaller is the bir
size it means the higher will be number
of iterations per EPO to perform to
ensure that the entire training data has
been used for updating the model
parameters so this also means that the
training time will be longer per Epoch
compared to the larger bed sizes where
we will go through the entire training
data so per Epoch we will have less
number of iteration so it will take much
less time per Epoch to train the model
but the problem is that in case of
larger bed sizes it can be Memory
intensive and may not always even be
feasible when we have a very small
machine not a powerful one in order to
perform the training uh so it comes also
with Hardware
limitations then another Factor you can
mention is the memory usage so a larger
bed size requires more memory whereas
the a smaller bed size requires less
memory so this is another factor that
comes into the overall performance of
your model and then we have the
convergence quality this we have spoken
a lot about so I will just briefly
mention uh when we have smaller bed size
the smaller is the badge size the higher
is usually the generalization of the
model but usually the lower is the
convergence quality because it's more
likely to catch the local Optimum
instead of global Optimum then when it
comes to the learning Dynamics then the
bch size will impact the motor's ability
to escape the local opum if we have the
uh smaller bed sizes and we are using
them when to estimate the the true
gradient then this this gradients will
be noisy which also means that the
learning will be inconsistent and it is
more likely to impact the quality of the
optimization process and to catch the
local optim inert Global Optimum and
overall if your batch size is small then
usually the algorithm is much more
instable rather than when we have large
badge size and the algorithm is much
more consistent in the update of model
parameters the next question is what is
Haitian and how it can be used for
faster training what are it
disadvantages so if you got a course in
differential Theory then you most likely
know what Haitian means uh here I would
just give you a very high level summary
of what haian is and I will go in much
more detail into the impact of using
haian in deep learning so Haitian comes
from a differential Theory and it is
basically a matrix that contains the
second order partial derivative of a
function which back to the parameters in
case of deep learning and as part of the
optimization process Haitian can play a
role of getting better and more accurate
estimates of the gradients because it
then will uh compute the second order
partial derivative of the loss function
with respect to the model parameters and
the reason why we are using Haan in some
cases in some adaptive learning
optimization algorithms which are more
improved version of SGD or HGD with
momentum is to have a better estimate
less noisy estimat of the true gradients
and you might recall that when we were
discussing the HGD and HGD with momentum
we were saying that our primary goal is
to reduce the number of oscilations as
much as possible because when we are
using a small bed size or just few
training observations to perform our
back prop and obtain the estimate of the
true gradients then usually this ends up
introducing instability in our model
because this gradients this estimate of
the gradients are not proper estimat of
the true gradients and to improve this
uh when we use Haitian Haitians are not
to be much more accurate estimate of the
gradients and they can help the
algorithm the optimization algorithm to
move towards more correct direction when
we are trying to update the moral
parameters so so using the same amount
of data but having less noisy gradients
and making more correct updates and take
a smoother direction towards the global
Optimum now this comes with certain
disadvantages because it's not that easy
to compute the haian so if we look at
this example this is an example of an
Haan Matrix and you can see that on the
diagonal we have simply the the second
order derivative of the function f with
respect to the parameter X1 but then
when it comes to multiple parameters so
when we have multiple parameters in our
model we then need to obtain the partial
derivative of the function in our case
the loss function with respect to the
model parameters and when you do it this
computation manually just as an example
just for fun you will discover that in
some cases when you have many parameters
in your model then it will be sometimes
super difficult to compute this second
order partial derivatives beside of that
this comes also at the cost of the
computational resources when it comes to
using hati as part of your optimization
algorithm because this results in uh
having this complicated functions
putting into the memory and storing this
information into the memory and this
haian Matrix can be extremely large for
or deep neural network models and this
will then result in the high number of
parameters making it sometimes
computationally invisible or very
expensive to calculate and to then
invert the uh gradients then the other
disadvantage of this haian usage is that
we might have a risk of overfitting
because when we are using this second
order derivative the second order
partial derivative um as way to
estimated to gradients we might might be
over relying on this haian for training
accelerations and this might result in
the moral memorizing the training data
and overly relying on the training data
when performing the parameter updates
which will mean that the moral will be
able will less likely generalize well on
nonen data which is of course a problem
because then our moral is overfitting
and it will be able to generalize well
on an in data which is our end goal the
next question is discuss the concept of
an Adaptive learning rate describe
adoptive learning methods so here we
need to talk both about the concept of
adaptive learning rate and we also need
to give you examples of optimization
algorithms that are known to be of
adaptive nature so when it comes to the
traditional GD HGD or HGD with momentum
so all the optimization algorithms that
we spoke about before all these
algorithms have single quality uh in
common that they are using exactly the
same learning rate when updating all
model parameters independent whether
those are weight parameters whether
those are uh bias factors or whether
they are different weight factors so
weight parameters for different hidden
layers now the Adaptive learning process
and adaptive learning rate uh in neural
network is quite different from this
constant learning rate so this learning
rate which we saw before defined by ITA
in deep learning can play a crucial role
when it comes to defining the step size
so how much we need to update the weight
parameters how much we need to update
the bias factors and it basically
defines the uh the amount of update we
need to make so what learning the
Adaptive learning process does is that
it says we should not use exactly the
same learning rate across all these
parameters instead we need to look at
the training data and we need to look at
the feature and based on that understand
and adopt the learning rate so the step
size that we need to use when updating
the model parameters because it can be
that we have this different features and
one feature can require a different
amount of updates such as learning uh
learning rate the step size versus the
other features that will require
different sorts of updates and that's
exactly what this adaptive learning
optimization process does so it handles
diverse data it's able to look into
these complex data sets and look into
this features and it then tries to
update the different model parameters
based on the corresponding information
that it's getting so from the learning
process from Computing the gradients and
then from this patterns in the different
features so in this way we are adopting
the learning rate accordingly and each
uh model parameter will have its own
learning rate so this will then avoid
having a stagnation and will definitely
uh reduce the oscilations because it
helps you prevent getting stuck in a
local minimum and not being able to
discover the global opum which is a
common issue when we have a F learning
rate now when it comes to different
examples of adaptive learning rate when
we have different learning rate and the
learning rate is being adopted based on
the information that it's getting from
the algorithm and training data there
are a few that you can mention and one
of the most popular optimization
algorithms that is also of adaptive
nature is the Adam optimization
algorithm So Adam that specifically
stands for adaptive moment estimation uh
which is then the algorithm that adopts
the learning rate accordingly and
therefore is also known to have much
better performance when it comes to
optimization so another example is the
RMS prop RMS prop stands for the root
mean squar propagation and this
algorithm has been introduced as one of
the cuser courses about deep learning
and from then on many people have been
using it and experimenting with it
another adaptive optimization Al Alm is
the Adaptive gradient algorithm which is
the aagr so this also adjust the
learning rate based on what we are
calling cumulative squared gradients and
it's particularly useful when you are
dealing with spars data so this is
basically at high level the summary of
the Adaptive optimization process what
it means to adapt the learning rate uh
the impact of it on the Deep learning
model performance as well as the
examples of few adapted optimization
algorithm largely used across the
industry the next question is what is
RMS prop and how does it work so we just
saw that RMS prop is one of the examples
that that can be defined as an Adaptive
optimization process and RMS probe
stands for the root mean squared
propagation and it is like GD HGD and
HGD with momentum an optimization
algorithm that tries to minimize the
loss function of your deep learning
model to find the set of moral
parameters that that will minimize the
loss function so uh what RMS probe does
is that it tries to address some of the
shortcomings of the traditional gradient
descent algorithm and it is especially
useful when we are dealing with
Vanishing gradient problem or exploring
gradient problem so we saw before that a
very big problem during the train
meaning of deep neural network is this
concept of Vanishing gradient or
exploring gradient so when the gradients
start to converge towards zero uh so
they become very small they almost
vanish uh or when the gradients are so
big that they are exploding so they are
becoming very large and they result in a
large amount of oscilations now uh to
avoid this what RMS prop is doing is
that it is using an Adaptive learning
rate it's adjusting the learning rate
and it is using for this for this
process this idea of running running
average of the second order gradients so
this is related to this concept of haian
and it is also using this DK parameter
uh which takes into account and
regulates uh what is the magnitude the
average of the magnitudes of the recent
gradients that we need to use where when
we are updating the model parameters so
basically what is the amount of
information that we need to take into
account from the recent adjustments so
in this case this means that parameters
with large gradients will have their
effective learning rate to be reduced so
whenever we have uh large gradients for
parameter we will be then reducing the
gradients this means that we will then
control the exploring gradient
effect uh and of course the other way
around holds true in case of RMS probe
for the parameters that will have a
small gradients we will be then
controlling this and we will be
increasing their learning rate to ensure
that the gradient will not Vish and in
this way we will be then controlling and
smoothing the process so the RMS prob
uses this DEC rate which you can see
here too this beta which is that a
number usually around 0.9 and it
controls how quickly this running
average forgets the all these gradients
so as you can see here uh we have this
running average VT which is equal to
Beta * VT minus 1 + 1 - beta * GT ^ 2 so
this is basically our uh second order
gradient so then what we are doing is
that we are taking this running average
and then we are using this to adapt and
to adjust our learning rate so you can
see here in our second expression the
Theta t + 1 so the updated version of
the parameter is equal to the Theta T so
the current parameter minus so we're
subtracting the learning rate divided to
square root of this VT square root of
this running average and we are adding
some Epsilon which is usually a small
number just to ensure that we are not
dividing this ITA to0 in case our
running average is equal to zero so we
are ensuring that this number still
exists and we do not divide a number to
zero and then we are simply multiplying
this to our gradient so as you can see
depending on our parameter we will then
have a different learning rate and we
will then be updating this learning so
by adapting this learning rate in case
of RMS prop we are then stabilizing this
optimization process we are then
preventing all these random movements
these
oscilations and at the same time we are
ensuring smoother convergence we are
also ensuring that our Network
especially for deep neural networks it
doesn't suffer from this Vanishing
radient problem and from the exploding
gradient problem which can be a serious
problem when we are trying to optimize
our deep neural network the next
question is what is atam and why is it
used most of the time in nural networks
So Adam is an Adaptive optimization
algorithm that is known for its Dynamic
learning adjustments based on the first
and the second moments of the gradients
So Adam like RMS prop is another
adaptive optimization algorithm which
adapts the learning rate accordingly in
order to reduce the amount of
oscilations and to improve the
optimization algorithms quality what
Adam tries to do is that it tries to
bring this benefits of two different
algorithms together it tries to combine
the idea of momentum from SGD with
momentum with the idea of the RMS probe
by using the running average of the
second order derivative so the second
moment and by combining the two it tries
then to take the benefits of the Two
Worlds so when it comes to the Adam it
can be represented by this mathematical
representation you don't need to know it
but I always think it helps to bring
perspective to how it combines the Two
Worlds the RMS probe and SGD with
momentum and why it is actually so
useful so when we look in here we can
see that the first one is the momentum
term so the Mt is equal to beta 1 * Mt
minus 1 plus 1 - beta 1 * GT where the
beta 1 is the firste which is simply a
constant uh and the beta 2 is also a
constant a hyper parameter both of which
we can actually tune so in here you can
see GT and GT squ which are simply the
first moment and the second moment of
our gradients where second moment is
known to be better estimate less noisy
compared to the first moment so what we
are trying to do is that we are on one
hand using this idea of
momentum in order to reduce the amount
of ciliation that the optimization
algorithm is making and in this way we
are improving the optimization process
and getting a better quality and on the
other hand we are also introducing this
idea of velocity which comes from the
RMS prob which then will result in
better less noisy estimate of the
gradients so by doing this what we are
trying to do is that we are adjusting
the learning rate throughout the
training process and we are making it
more effective across different
scenarios so for scenarios where GD
would momentum would have been better
Adam will incorporate this and where it
would be beneficial to use RMS prop then
Adam would again the a optimization
algorithms and that's why Adam has been
proven across the entire industry to be
very effective and people are using it
across the industry uh for wide range of
problems and applications
so as you can see once we have our
running average for the first order
derivative and the running average for
our second moment gradient then we are
also adjusting so we are correcting this
momentum and the velocity uh by dividing
this Mt so we are taking the Mt and we
are dividing it to 1 minus beta 1 T
because we want to adjust for the bias
when it comes to this momentum and then
we are also adjust the velocity so VT
head is then the adjusted version of the
VT because we take the VT and we divide
it to 1 minus beta 2 to the^ T by using
the beta 2 as our hyper parameter as our
second bias vector and then we are using
this adjusted running average for the
first moment and the adjusted version of
the running average of our second order
gradient in order to update and adapt
our learning rate and as you can see
here what we are doing we are taking the
learning rate Alpha we are multiplying
it by the adapted and adjusted momentum
term and then we are dividing it to the
square root of this velocity term or VT
hat plus some Epsilon which is usually a
small number just to ensure that we are
not dividing this number to zero and we
are using this to subtract from the
Theta T so the current parameter to get
our new updated parameter Theta t + one
so so when it comes to the benefits of
using the Adam first of all Adam
incorporates this benefits from multiple
optimization algorithms to ensure that
the quality is in place and the
efficiency is in place and the the
optimization algorithm is able to handle
different
scenarios uh the efficiency with spse
gradients is another advantage of Adam
Optimizer because Adam is particularly
efficient when dealing with this sparse
gradient and uh the other advantage of
Adam is that it's able to balance the
speed and the stability So Adam
generally converges much faster when it
comes to the converging to the global
opum compared to algorithm such as HGD
and at the same time it also tends to be
more stable because it's able to control
the it's able to control the learning
process compared to the algorithms that
only use the first moment uh whereas the
the atom is is also using the uh second
order gradients so the second moment and
the final advantage of Adam is that it
is robust so it's known for its
robustness in various conditions and
various scenarios uh which also means
that it is less sensitive to
hyperparameter choices and this is
especially important when it comes to
the initial learning rate and this makes
it much more easy and user friendly for
large range of applications especially
when you are someone who is just
learning deep learning then it can be a
bit difficult to tune your
hyperparameters it can be difficult to
identify this initial values that you
need to use for your algorithm and Adam
is then less sensitive to this choice of
learning rate which can be really
important what is Adam W and why it is
preferred over Adam so here we are of
course referring to the atam
optimization algorithm that we just
discussed and the Adam W is simply the
adjusted version of the traditional Adam
Optimizer so like Adam Adam W is an
Adaptive optimization algorithm that is
used to optimize the training of a
neural network and to find the minimal
point of the loss function by
continuously adopting the learning rate
and updating the model parameters so the
biggest difference in Adam W and Adam is
the way they perform this
regularization so the traditional Adam
has one specific disadvantage which
usually comes uh when dealing with deep
neural networks so unlike the uh
traditional SGD with momentum Adam is
unable to properly generalize the moral
and most of the time when we are
performing regularization with Adam so
let's say we are using L2 re
regularization uh with Adam in order to
penalize uh large weights and in order
to address the overfitting problem of
the algorithm then Adam has shown in the
industry when training different deep
neural network to not generalize very
well and to solve this problem of
overfitting so that's exactly what Adam
W tries to do it tries to address the
specific problem of Adam such that we
can have improved generalization and it
can address the shortcomings of the
traditional Adam making it one of the
best algorithms out there and it's being
used more and more in across Varian
applications and this is especially true
when it comes to fine-tuning already
pre-trained model because those type of
models are known to have this problem of
overfitting and we need to have General
model when the problem of overfitting
will not be S so absent so present and
we will be able to to pre-train the
model find H the model this pre uh based
on this pre-trained model and then use
this on an unseen data and the model
will still perform well so this
basically solving the problem of
overfitting and ensuring that we have
improved
generalization that's what adamw does
and the way it does that is that like
you can see here unlike the traditional
Adam with L2 regularization for instance
what it does is that it adds this DC so
this penalization term right in the
update process when updating the model
parameters so the traditional Adam
algorithm when combined with L2
regularization where Adam is the
optimization algorithm and L2 is the
regularization algorithm to solve the
overfitting uh what we do is that we add
this Lambda multiplied by Theta T minus
one where Lambda is this uh penalization
parameter we use to understand how much
we need to penalize certain parameters
and this is to ensure that we that the
model doesn't memorize the training data
and it ensures that uh the model the
model is more
generalizable now when we uh do this
sometimes this doesn't help us that much
to solve the overfeeding problem and the
weight Decay so decoupling this weight
decay from this gradient updates and
instead of using this as part of this
gradient update if we incorporate this
as part of the directly as part of the
model parameter updates then it has
proven to have much better impact in
terms of generalization of the model so
when we add this regularization term
Lambda multiply by Theta T minus one not
to the gradient but we add it directly
when updating the model parameter as
part of this uh entire uh expression as
you can see multiplied with the learning
rate then this has shown to have much
better impact in terms of solving the
overfitting problem and making the
entire training trained model more
generalizable which will then ensure
that uh we have better performance in
specific scenarios especially when we
have uh deep naral networks or when we
are fire tuning pre-trained model and
this also means that the algorithm uh
will perform equally well on an unseen
data unlike when we are using the
traditional Adam which in some scenarios
doesn't perform generalization very well
and It suffers from overfitting the next
question is what is badge normalization
and why it is used in neural networks so
a b normalization to understand this
concept you need to know what is a
normal distribution so the standard
normal distribution is a probability
distribution function that has a mean
equal to zero and a variance equal to
one and what bch normalization does is
that it normalizes the activations per
batch hence the name bch normalization
so bch normalization is this technique
that is introduced to address the issue
of uh this internal covariant shift uh
in the neural networks and what this
refers is that uh there will be a change
in the distribution of the network
activations due to the changes in the
parameters of a naral network so every
time when we are using the back prop we
are Computing the gradients then we are
using the optimization algorithm to
update those model parameters this then
will introduce this change in the
distribution of activations which can
then destabilize our naral Network and
it's something that we don't want to
have uh for better performance of our
algorithm and our narrow Network we want
our batches to have certain preferred
distributional properties so we want it
to be uh for instance normally
distributed which is known to be one of
the most go-to uh distribution functions
in statistics in machine learning and by
uh normalizing the activation so once we
compute our Z course we apply our
activation function and we get our
activations then we can normalize this
activations by Computing the mean and by
Computing the variance of these
activations across the batch so for all
the observations perir batch and then we
can use this in order to normalize the
activations now you you will most likely
be familiar with this concept of
normalization if you have used
traditional machine learning models but
let's quickly look into the mathematical
definitions just in case you you also
need to provide this as part of your
answer
so when we look in here you can see that
we are Computing the mean of all the
activations where XI defines the
activations and M is the number of
observations per batch we are taking the
sum of all these activations and we are
dividing it to the number of
observations per batch this then gives
us our uh batch mean so mu batch and
then we can also compute the
corresponding variance of the batch by
taking this activations XI and
subtracting from this the mean of the
batch and taking the square of this so
the square difference of the
activations uh and the mean of the batch
and we are taking the sum of them for
all the badge observations so M elements
and dividing it to the number of all
observations per batch in this way we
can find an estimate of variance of this
batch and we can then use this to
normalize
the activations of this batch so as you
can see here we are taking the XI so
activations we are subtracting the mub
the mean of the batch and dividing it to
the square root of the sigma B squ so
the variance of the batch and we are
adding some noise so the Epsilon to
ensure that we we do not divide this
number to zero and then once we have
this activations we can then use this
normalized activations to obtain our
predictions so this picture is a common
picture that is used to visualize this
idea of bch normalization because here
we have all the observations of the bch
so we have n different observations
according to this picture and then we
need to normalize this pair feature so
you can see that we are normalizing pair
feature all the observations perir batch
so we are using all the observations per
batch to find the main for that feature
and to find a variance of that feature
and then we are Computing the normalized
activations uh now you might be thinking
but why do we even normalize it beside
of stabilizing the neural network and
how does that even affect the the
stability of the neural network so when
we perform normalization using this bch
Norm uh bch Norm introduces this two
trainable parameters per Activation so
one one for the scale and one for the
shift so the scale is then this SMU and
then the shift is then the variance so
once we have this the step ensures that
the normalization process doesn't
diminish the representational capacity
of the network so in this way what we
are doing is that we are stabilizing the
distribution of the activations across
different layers so in each layer we
don't have entirely different
distribution for activations and when we
have similar distributions and this is
just normal then we will have more
stable learning process and this will
then allow for Higher Learning rates uh
which will then accelerate the training
process of a neural network and when we
are accelerating the training process we
are making a lesser amount of this
oscilations which we saw was a big
problem as part of the traditional sgds
and the Lesser we are making making
oscilations the higher is the chance
that we will quickly and smoothly go
towards the global Optimum and we will
find the global Optimum of our loss
function the next benefit of using bch
normalization is that it reduces the
sensitivity of the algorithm to the uh
initialization so when we are training
our Nal Network we need to have uh
initialization for our weights and for
our bias sectors and this weight
initialization can influence
significantly the final outcome of the
naral network and it might even entirely
change and put the algorithm towards
wrong direction so towards local minimum
when we are trying to optimize the
algorithm and when we perform bch
normalization then the algorithm will be
less sensitive to this initial values of
the weights which means also that we
will have higher chance to find a global
op op instead of the local opum then the
final indirect impact of this bch
normalization is the regularization
impact so bch normalization is usually
done for stabilizing the neural network
but the indirect impact of the
circularization indirect impact of this
normalization is that it has a
regularization impact so what then this
algorithm does is that it slightly
regularizes the neural network and it
reduces the need for using other
regularization algorithms that would uh
try to solve the overfitting problem and
the way moral does this is that by
normalizing the activations it ensures
that some of the neurons doesn't get too
high
activations uh and this will then be
some noise points which will end up
impacting the outcome of the entire
neural network because if the uh
training happens on some noise data
points as part of a training data and
the the morel focuses on this noise
points and learns this memorizes the
data points which are not supposed to be
memorized then the updates that the
model will make will be based on this to
high but noisy points when we are
performing normalization and we are
reducing the impact of this noise points
it means also that we are also reducing
the risk of the moral following this
noise too heavily and impacting the
entire moral update which then on its
turn reduces the risk of overfitting so
it has a regularization impact for naral
Network the next question is what is
layer normalization and why it is used
in naral networks so a layer
normalization uh like veg normalization
tries to stabilize the network and
reduce the internal covariate shift of
the activations to ensure that the
neural network is able to properly learn
the in a stable way dependencies in the
data so we just saw that batch
normalization uses the entire training
data of one batch when Computing the
mean and the variance and Performing
normalization per feature now unlike the
bch normalization the way layer
normalization does this normal
normalization process is that it
computes the mean across all features
not one but all features for a single
training observation and does it the
same for the variant so it computes the
variant across all features but single
training observation and then uses this
to normalize these
activations so the reason for this
change is that in some cases in certain
neural network architectures it is pH
the feasibility is not there so we
cannot even calculate it just doesn't
make sense to perform normalization
across all training observations because
of the structure of the our architecture
and also the uh input data nature for
instance when we have CNN based on this
architecture we can then use the bch
normalization easily but when we have
this architecture such as RNN or lstms
or grus then using bch normalization is
not effective and layer normalization
has proven to be much more effective in
those cases so therefore for this
different sorts of architectures we can
then use layer normalization whenever it
is not possible to use B normalization
layer normalization is largely used also
in the state-of-the-art Transformers
which are a part of the trendy large
language model such as gpts which are
encoder only but also the decoder only
architectures uh such as bird
and if you're wondering why layer Norm
is particularly used in architectures
like RNN or lstms or grus or
Transformers it is because in those kind
of architectures the bed size is either
small or it can vary and whenever we
have this varying or small bch sizes
then bch Norm usually is not effective
and unlike V Norm layer Norm in those
cases is particularly effective so like
in RNN or in grus or lstms where
regarding of the P size which can be
different uh the layer Norm will still
perform effectively when it comes to
stabilizing the network the next
question is what are residual
connections and their function in naral
networks so residual connections have a
very important function in naral
networks and specifically they try to
optimize the performance of naral
networks by combating the infamous
Vanishing gradient problem the residual
connections they play a key role in deep
learning architectures like rest net
Transformers uh the um the GPT series
large language models as model so if you
look at the paper called attention is
all you need then you'll most likely see
as part of the architecture in each of
these layers beside of having the actual
layer you will also see this additional
layer which says at and then Norm so
this is exactly where the layer
normalization comes and the residual
connections are added so what the
residual connection does is that in this
unlike the typical naral network uh
where the input is simply transformed
through the weights and the bias vectors
into the corresponding activations to
produce the output in case of residual
connections we are adding the the
original input directly on the output of
this layer and this is often referred to
us as a short cat or a skip connection
and the reason why it is called a short
cat or a skip connection is because the
gradients are simply skipping through
this transformation of this
computational graph of being transformed
towards the multiplication with the
weights adding bias factors and then uh
using the activation function as
transform
and instead of that it has also a direct
shortcut towards contributing to the
final outcome so as you can see here
with residual connections we have the
output equal to the FX which is a
transformation so it's the output of
that layer plus the actual X which is
the input so going back to this example
of the Transformer model in the original
paper attention is All You Need You
Might Recall from the Transformer
architecture this part which is the left
part so the encoder part of the
Transformer model it's also used as part
of the GPT Series so the general
pre-trained model uh where we are so the
Transformer model where we are using the
input uh so the input embeddings on the
top of that positional encodings uh
based on the sinusoids and cinos oids
and then on that after that we are
transforming this into cues keys and
values if you are familiar with
Transformer model and then this goes us
an input to the multi-ad attention layer
so if you're are not familiar with this
architecture of Transformers just forget
about that don't mind the details just
think of like this multi-ad attention
layer as a layer in your neural network
that tries to learn the uh inter
dependences between elements of your
sequence so what we are doing here is
that beside of providing this input
those positional encodings added on the
top of the input encodings beside of
giving that as an input to the multi had
ATT tension layer which then gives us an
output the transformed version uh we are
also giving this value this input you
can see with this Arrow going to the on
the top of that output so we are getting
the output from the multi tension layer
and on the top of that we are performing
layer normalization and we are adding
the input on this output and this is
exactly what we are doing as part of
residual connections we are adding the
input on the top of that
output now uh the reason why it is
called shortcut it is because when
Computing the gradients uh the gradient
will then go through this
Transformations we need to compute the
partial derivative of the loss function
with respect to the weights and for that
we first need to calculate the partial
derivative of the loss function with
respect to the Z scores and then we need
to compute the partial derivative of the
Z of the Z scores with respect to the
weights and then use the two and use the
chain rule to compute the partial
derivative of the loss function with
respect to weights now this entire
transformation of this gradients will
result in many cases the gradient coming
very close to zero and Vanishing so this
is the INF famous Vanishing gradient
problem and to avoid this what we are
doing with residual connection is that
we have also this shortcut so you can
see that we are not only performing this
different transformation so we have X
then we have the weight layer then we
have the rectifier linear unit
activation then we have weight layer and
then we are getting the output which is
the FX and on the top of that we are
also adding this x so the initial input
on the top of this
output this is what we are calling
residual connections and the reason why
you can see that we have this idea of
shortcut so the gradient is able to flow
into network not only through this
Transformations but also directly
towards the gradient is because of this
mathematical derivation here so if we
look at the output Y is equal to x + FX
where X is the input that we are adding
on the top of the output FX you can see
that if we take the partial derivative
of this function uh X+ FX with respect
to the X then what we need to do is we
need to apply the chain so we need to
take the partial derivative of the E
with respect to the Y then multiply it
with the partial derivative of y with
respect to the X which is equal to the
partial derivative of e with respect to
Y so exactly the same as we have here
but then multiplied with 1 + FX or F
first order derivative X I have to say
uh and the reason why it is is this
value because as you can see here we
need to take the partial derivative of y
with respect to X and as y isal to x +
FX when we take the partial derivative
of X Plus FX with respect to x uh using
the um uh the rule for summation the
differentiation of sums then this is
simply equal to the derivative of the X
with respect to X which is one plus the
derivative of FX with respect to X which
is f and then this not X which basically
is the first order derivative of FX with
respect to X so as you can see here when
we open this parenthesis this is the
same as taking the partial derivative of
a with respect to Y and then adding to
this the partial derivative of e with
respect to y * f x and this is simply
opening parenthesis so one multiply with
this value which gives us the first
order derivative of e with respect to
one y plus and then we have this second
part of the within the parenthesis which
is the FX multiplied with the uh partial
derivative of a with respect to Y which
is simply the partial derivative of e
with respect to Y multiplied by f x so
what we can see here and the reason why
I am explaining this mathematical
derivation is that you can see for
yourself that the gradient in this case
uh with respect to X will be able to not
only flow through this part which is the
multiplied by
FX which has gone through all these
transformations of the weight and in
activation function but also directly
because we have here this term partial
derivative of e with respect to Y and
why this is helpful and how this is
reducing thetion gradient problem is
because when we have this multiple
layers by the time we come from this
very deep layers to the very earlier
layers our gradient goes through all
these transformations of the weights
activation functions and then it ends up
becoming very close to zero so it's
Vanishing and if we have this
opportunity for the gradient to go
through the shortcut and flip through
and Skip some of the layers we will have
higher chance of this gradient to not
vanish and to actually reach from deeper
layers to the initial layers and that's
exactly what we want to do and this
solves the problem of Vanishing gradient
what is gradient clipping and their
impact on neural network so we just saw
the residual connections and we saw that
residual connections especially for deep
neural network and specifically for the
cases like RNN lstms when we have the
sequential nature with too many layers
uh we can have this Vanishing gradient
problem and residual connections can
help to solve this problem now gradient
clipping is solving the opposite problem
so it's solving the exploring gradient
problem
whenever we have certain deep neural
networks like RNN lstms because we are
each time using these Transformations
and we are using a cumulative nature and
multiplying all these weights towards
each other through this process and we
are using the previous hidden state to
update the the new hidden state so next
hidden State and next one it also means
that when we are going through these
layers during the uh optimization
process after backrop is done we need to
perform all these Transformations and by
the time we come through the earlier
layers it can be that we have exploding
gradients so the gradients become so
large that it starts to impact the
entire performance of the model we are
starting to make two big over jumps and
the updates that we are starting to get
and optimization process is starting to
make too much of this oscilations
towards different directions so we are
seeing this ertic Behavior as part of
our optimization process and that's
definitely not something that we want to
have because exploring gradients means
that we have unstable naral network and
uh this also means that the update of
the weights will be too large and this
will then result in not well performing
and not properly train neural network
now to avoid all these problems the way
we can solve this explode gradient uh
problem is by using the uh gradient
clipping what gradient clipping does is
that it basically Clips the gradients at
a certain level so there is a threshold
which is the parameter that we are using
for gradient clipping and whenever the
gradient becomes too large so higher
than the threshold then we will be
clipping that gradient to ensure that
this gradient is not too large and we
are not updating our weight parameters
or bias sectors too much so in this way
what we are doing is that we are kind of
stabilizing our neural network which is
especially important for architectures
like lstms RNN grus uh which have this
sequential nature of the data with too
many layers and uh in this way we will
ensure that we do not have this ertic
jumps in our naral Network optimization
process and we will end up with a stable
Network that is able to properly learned
interdependencies so the key ID behind
cavier initialization is to keep the
variance of the activations and the
gradients consistent across layers the
way it is done it is by setting the
initial weights based on the number of
input and the output neurons in a neural
network so the way it works is that it
looks into the n in which is is simply
the number of uh neurons uh as the
inputs that go into that layer and the N
output which is the number of neurons or
the output as part of that layer because
in each layer we have neurons that comes
in and the neurons that come out and
This n in that comes in and N Out that
describes the number of neurons that go
out is being used in order to define the
distribution of this weights so Ty so
one way that the cier initialization
tries to stabilize the network and keep
the gradients as well as the activations
consistent and stable is by using uh
certain statistical distributions uh
with certain qualities that will ensure
that the variance of the weights is
constant so we want to come up with a
distribution from which we will sample
our initial weights using the n in which
is the number of neurons that go into
that layer and N Out which is the number
of neurons that go out of that layer
using that combined with the statistical
distribution so one way of doing that is
by using the uniform distribution if
you're familiar with the statistical
distribution function uh the the way
uniform distribution works is that it
always has the two parameters it has a
lower bound a and the upper bound B and
the distribution always lies within this
specific area it's like a rectangular
area uh and the corresponding values so
the upper bound is the probability is 1
/ B minus a so the probability for all
the values that lie in within that range
is constant it's equal to 1 / B minus a
now why this is important in our case it
is because if we use certain A and B in
this case you can see when using square
root of 6 / to square root of n plus n
out as a lower bound and is positive
version so square root of 6 / to a sare
root of n in plus N Out then the
variance corresponding to this random
variable that follows uniform
distribution with this lower bound a and
lower B the upper bound B will be then
equal to 2 / 2 square root of n in plus
N Out so the variance of this random
distribution will be this amount and
this means that every time we have this
weight weight this weight will then be
constant so the variation of it will be
constant and what does it mean if the
weight has a constant variance it means
that it will always change in a similar
amount of with similar amount so it will
not change too much with too high
gradients so exploring gradients it will
also not change too low so the gradients
will not be too small so we will also
combat The Vanishing gradient problem
and and that's why cavier initialization
can be so important and so significant
because it can help to stabiliz the
entire network it can bring consistency
into the variance of these activations
and the gradients across different
layers and it will also reduce this risk
of Vanishing and exploding gradients
which will promote stability and it will
also improve the efficiency of your
training process and this
process it is particularly relevant for
the sigmoid activation function and the
tank activation
function let's now look into the next
question so what are the different ways
to solve Vanishing gradient problem so
by now we have discussed many topics and
many approaches where I have briefly
mentioned that this helps you solve the
venish gradient problem for example so
here I will just summarize at higher
level very quickly what are the
approaches that you can mention that
solve the vanishing gradient problem so
the Vishing gradient problem firstly can
be solved by using appropriate
activation functions so by using
activation functions such as rectifier
linear unit function or leaky rectifier
linear unit function that do not suffer
from
saturation uh this activation functions
can help to solve the vening gradient
problem and ensure that your gradients
will not vanish in your in those deep
networks by the time you come from this
very deep layers to the early
layers uh if you use the so don't use
the sigmoid don't use the tank but use
the Leaky reu or reu in order to combat
the vention gradient problem another way
that you can solve this problem is what
we just discussed in the previous
question which is the cavier
initialization so choosing an
appropriate weight initialization
technique can help you to combat The
Vanishing gradient
problem
another way to solve this problem is by
performing bch normalization so bch
normalization indirectly will introduce
stability into the network and by
normalizing the activations it will also
result in your gradients which will be
more consistent and if your gradients
are more consistent it also means that
you have lesser chance of having a
problem of Vanishing
gradients then another way that you can
solve the gradient problem especially
when it comes to sequence-based
architectures like RNN lsms
grus uh in all those cases you can use
residual connections so residual
connections will help you to open the
door for the shortcut for your gradients
to flip through your network without per
without going through all this
Transformations and this will then on
its turn help you reduce the risk of
Vanishing gradients
then the final way of combating the
vening gradient problem is by using an
appropriate architecture so whenever you
have you have a choice of choosing
certain architectures then try to make
use of the ones that are more
appropriate for your data more
appropriate for your problem and this
will avoid at least at some extent the
chance of having Vanishing gradient
problem if you are for instance making
use of the Transformer architecture then
in here we are automatically also adding
this residual connections and layer
normalizations after each layer and this
helps you combat The Vanishing gradients
problem at some extent and if we are for
instance using the Adam V this also
helps to regularize the network and in
some way also solve this problem the
next question is what are the ways to
solve exploding gradients so one way of
solving EXP floating gradient like we
just spoke about is the gradient
clipping so gradient clipping can help
to keep this threshold and ensure that
every time the gradients are checked
with respect to this threshold and every
time when we have gradients that are
about to explode so they go beyond the
threshold it will then clip the
gradients and it will ensure that the
gradients will not go over this level
and this will then solve the problem of
exploding
gradients another way you can solve this
problem is by using the weight
initialization in a proper way so as we
saw before cavier initialization will
help us to not only solve the problem of
Vanishing gradients but also the problem
of exploring gradients because by
keeping the variance of the weight
constant we ensure that the gradi
gradients will not go not explode so not
grow too much also not grow too little
so too vanish so in this way weight
regularization and weight initialization
will also help to combat the exploding
gradient problem the next question is
what happens if the neural network is
suffering from overfitting uh relate to
weights in neural network so there are
two portions of this in this question
and the first part refers to the
overfitting problem so you need to show
that you understand how overfitting
relates to neural network usually this
is similar to the overfitting of machine
learning models uh and the second part
is to relate the overfitting to the ways
in narrow Network so let's start with
the first part so what is overfitting
overfitting happens when the model that
we are using in this case a deep uh
learning model uh it starts to memorize
the training data and when training the
model it tries to ensure that the model
performs well specifically on the
training data even though training data
might might contain some noise points
not General points some outliers and
when we train our model on this type of
data and model starts to memorize this
and we use this fitted data a fitted
model to train on and unseen data then
what we will see is that this
overfitting model is not performing well
on an unseen data whereas our entire
goal is to train the model on a training
data in such a way that this fin version
the fitted version of the model will
properly perform on an unseen data
that's our entire goal otherwise we
would not be using predictions in the
first place we want to have a proper
prediction with high accuracy for a
future data or unseen new data and
that's something that overfitting causes
a problem with because it makes the
model less generalizable it will not
generalize well on unseen data now now
how it is related to the weights of the
model so large weights in a neural
network will make the model very
sensitive to its input data which might
also include outliers or noise data and
when the model follows training data too
closely which also includes these
unusual points then this model will not
generalize well to the new data and
therefore that's something that we don't
want to have we want to solve the
problem of overfitting to ensure sure
that our model is generalizable and will
also perform equally well or at least at
some extent very similar to the
performance of the training data when we
introduce the model to the new data the
next question is what is drop out and
how does it work so Dropout is a
regularization technique commonly used
in deep learning specifically in order
to solve the problem of
overfitting so we just saw in the
previous interview question question
that overfitting can cause a lot of
problems uh when training neural
networks and we want to have ideally a
model that generalizes well on an unseen
data and one way to make our model more
generalizable and improve the
performance of our model is by using a
regularization technique and one very
popular regularization technique in
naral networks is Dropout so what
Dropout regularization does is that it
randomly drop out or deactivates a
subset or of neurons in your neural
network during each training
iteration and the way it does is that it
takes this probability or you can also
say proportion and this p is simply a
value between 0 and one and this refers
to the amount of or proportions of
neurons that needs to be randomly
deactivated so p is the dropout rate and
we are saying that the rgl which is
simply the activations in the layer l
that this random variable follows barol
distribution with one minus P
probability uh where 1 minus p is simply
equal to the amount of OBS amount of
neons that should not be deactivated so
amount of errors that should be
activated and if you have p as the
deactivation r then 1 minus P will be
the activation rate and why baroli
because if you are familiar with some
very popular statistical probability
distributions you will know that barol
distribution helps us to uh Express and
Define random variables that have two
possible outcomes there can be either
success or failure so there can be
either dropping out or not dropping out
we can either activate or not activate
so deactivate neurons and that's why we
are saying that our activations in that
specific layer let's say layer l can be
described by a random variable that
follows bare noly distribution with
activation rate of one minus P where p
is the dropout rate so think of it like
if we want to randomly deactivate or
drop during the training iteration 20%
of our activation of our neurons then
this P will be equal to 0.2 which means
that our activation rate will be equal
to 0.8 so our layer will follow a baroli
distribution with 0.8 as 0.8 being equal
the success
probability so then what we will doing
is that during only the training process
in each tion we will randomly deactivate
and drop out some of the neurons and in
this this way we will ensure that every
time our model sees only 80% of the
activations and how does this help to
solve the overfitting is because we
reduce the uh chance of our model seeing
the noise points and memorizing the
training data because if our model sees
every time 80% of the neurons and every
time it's changing from iteration to
iteration
this 80% cuz the process is random then
we have smaller chance for our Network
to every time see the same noise and to
memorize training data cuz we are kind
of decorrelating the training
process and what this then will help to
do is that it will make our neural
network more as table and less dependent
on certain neurons and it also means
that it will generally ize better it
will reduce the chance of
overfitting there is however a
catch um which comes that uh we are
performing the Dropout only at the
training data and later on in the
upcoming questions we will see how we
can answer those type of questions what
exactly we need to do given that we are
performing Dropout only on the training
data the next question is how does
Dropout prevent overfitting in naral
Networks so we already answered majority
of this question so I will just at high
level summarize what I just said as part
of the question 41 so the way Dropout
prevents the overfitting in the network
is that it randomly deactivates p% of
the neurons during the training process
which then reduces the dependency of the
neural network on certain data points
and reduces the chance of the network to
memorize the training data in this way
the network uh encourages the feature
redundancy and also helps to generalize
the model better the next question is is
drop out like random Forest so in this
question your interviewer wants to test
to very tricky way whether do you
understand the differences between
Dropout and random Forest as well as
their
similarities now let's first start with
the common goal that the two algorithms
have so the both drop out and the random
Forest they aim to improve the
robustness of your model and they reduce
the chance and the risk of overfitting
by introducing Randomness and diversity
in the training
process you might recall the random
Forest algorithm which is an emble
machine learning algorithm can be used
for both classification and for
regression and the way algorithm works
is that it tries to use the boot
bootstrapped B different bootstrap
samples which are copies of the original
training data only with
replacement and uses this B different uh
training copies in order to build B
different trees but it does this by
decorrelating the trees so making them
uncorrelated unlike the backing uh by
using randomly selected M features when
performing the splitting of the trees so
when the trees in random Forest are
built because in this recursive uh
building process in each step the
algorithm randomly selects M out of all
P features when splitting the tree so
when making this decision uh of where we
need to split the tree and to what
region the observation needs to be
assigned this introduces Randomness to
the algorithm and this Randomness helps
to decorrelated trees and then the
algorithm ends up having B uncorrelated
different decision trees and then it
combines them all therefore it's called
also emble algorithm and then takes the
average across all these different B
trees in order to get the final
prediction so in case of classification
that's the majority class in case of
regression that's the average of all the
outputs now this helps the random Forest
to combat the overfitting unlike the
backing and as the um average of
uncorrelated variables has a lower
variance than the average of correlated
variables in this way we help it helps
to reduce the variance and this then on
its turn helps to reduce the risk of
overfitting and makes the model more
generalizable so Dropout also tries to
kind of decorrelate process only the way
it does it is by uh deactivating certain
neurons and in each iteration use a
different uh portion of training data in
order to train the model and on his turn
this helps to avoid overfitting and
avoid the network memorizing the
training data so in both ways and in
both approaches the modals are
introducing this random component
Dropout by randomly dropping so certain
neurons random Forest by randomly
selecting M different features when
performing the recursive splits and
building decision trees in order to make
the modals more generalizable and reduce
the risk of
overfitting now the key differences so
how Dropout and random Forest are
different well Dropout is a technique
with a single model we have just single
narrow Network we are using exactly the
same training data and we are randomly
dropping neurons in order to in each
iteration have a different uh portion of
training neurons in order to make the
morel more
generalizable unlike the random Forest
which is an emble technique so it uses B
different copies from the original data
that samples it with replacement and
then uses this B different data sets in
order to build B different trees
and then combined this B different
models to create single model
so this means that the two algorithms
work entirely different also one is more
a regularization technique the other one
is an actual algorithm that can be used
on its own the next question is what is
the impact of Dropout on a training
versus testing when we were discussing
the Dropout I briefly mentioned that
dropout is only applied on a training
data which means that we are only
randomly deactivating the
activations uh as part of our training
process but this also means that the
neurons have smaller and specifically
one minus P probability of being
activated during the training process so
we are reducing the probability of a
neuron to be selected for being
activated
and this will then introduce
inconsistency when it comes to the
testing process because we are applying
the drop out only during the training
this also means that we need to address
this reduce in the activation
probability when we are performing the
testing so given that p% of the neurons
during the training are dropped or
deactivated we need to compensate for
this and we need to ensure that we have
consistency in the input size and for
that what we need to do is that we need
to scale the activations in the testing
by 1 minus p and in this way we will
then compensate for the small
probability difference that we were
making when we were dropping out certain
activations so just as an example if the
dropout rate is 20% so
0.2 this means that during the training
process the neurons have 80% probability
of being activated and 20% chance of not
being activated it means that during the
testing we need to scale the activations
by using 0.8 so 1 minus P the next
question is what are L2 or L1
regularizations and how do they prevent
overfitting in their own network so both
L1 and L2 regularizations are shrinkage
or regularization techniques that are
both used both in traditional machine
learning and in deep learning in order
to prevent the moral overfitting so
trying to make the model more
generalizable like the
Dropout so you might know from the
traditional machine learning models what
does L1 and L2 regularization do L2
regularization is also referred as Rich
regression and L1 regularization is also
referred as l or regression so what L1
regularization does is that it adds as a
normalization or as a regularization or
as a penalization factor that is based
on this penalization parameter Lambda
multiplied by this term which is based
on the absolute value of the weights so
this is different from the L2
regularization which is the reach
regularization and this regularization
adds to our loss function the
regularization ation term which is based
on the Lambda so the penalization
parameter multiplied by the square of
the weight so you can see how the two
are different one is based on what we
are calling the L1 norm and the other
one is based what we are calling L2 Norm
hence the names L1 and L2
regularization so both of them are used
with the same motivation to prevent
overfitting what L1 does different from
L2 is that L1 can set the weight of
certain neurons exactly equal to zero so
in some way also performing feature
selection whereas L2 regularization it
shrinks the weights towards zero but it
never sets them exactly equal to zero so
in this aspect L2 doesn't perform
feature selection and it only performs
regularization whereas L1 can be used
not only for uh shrinking the weights
and regularizing the network but also
also for performing feature selection
when you have too many
features so you might be wondering but
how does this help to prevent
overfitting well when you uh shrink the
weights towards zero and you are trying
to regularize this small or large
weights then this methods such as L1 or
L2 regularization they will ensure that
the moral doesn't overfit to the
training data so you will then regular
regularize the weights and this will
then on its turn regularize the network
because the weights will Define how much
of this Behavior ertic Behavior will be
prevented if you have two large weights
and you reduce them and you regularize
them it will ensure that you don't have
exploring gradients it will also uh
ensure that the network doesn't heavily
rely on certain neurons and this will
then ensure that your moto is not
overfitting and not memorizing straining
data which might also include noise and
outlier points now what is the
difference between L2 and L1
regularization approaches so I did
briefly mention the difference of the
two now let's look into more detailed
version of it so L2 regularization also
known as Rich regularization at squared
weight values to the loss function so
it's also called L2 Norm so as you can
see we are taking the weights wi we are
squaring them we are summing them up for
that specific layer and we are
multiplying it by a regularization
parameter also referred as penalization
parameter Lambda hence the name ll2
which basically means that this is the
regularization term for the L2
regularization or the reach
regularization now when it comes to the
impact of this L2 regularization is that
it will shrink the weight weights
towards zero but it does this in a very
proportional way so it tries to make the
weights more equal towards each other uh
so it will have a bigger impact on the
large weights because it will try to
make it equal to the smaller weights but
it will have lesser impact on the
smaller weights in this way it will try
to proportionally spread over the ways
towards different neurons and it will
try to ensure that all this different
neurons have kind of equal
proportionally equal uh impact uh on the
training process whereas when it comes
to L1 regularization which is based on
L1 Norm also referred as ler
regularization uh it adds to the loss
function the added so the sum of the
absolute value of the
weights so you can see here that it's
equal to Lambda multiplied by the sum of
all the absolute values of w w i we of
our neural network so the way L1
regularization works is that it adds
these absolute values which then shrinks
the weights toward zero and in some
cases it sets certain weights and
specifically those small weights exactly
equal to zero so in this way L1
regularization punishes the small
weights so it's heavily shrinking those
weights and set them equal to exactly
zero and it has less of a punishment
effect and is less harsh on this large
weights and in this way it also performs
feature selection because all the
neurons so the features that have a
weight of zero so they have uh their
weight become zero it means that they
are no longer being no longer
contributing to the network let's
briefly look at the difference between
the two in this table to clarify so when
it comes to the feature selection
process L1 performs feature selection L2
doesn't because L1 said certain weights
exactly equal to zero when it comes to
the smoothing process L1 it has a less
smoothing effect because it's very harsh
on the small weights it sets them
exactly equal to zero and less on the
large weights L2 is bit different it's
less harsh of a method and it is more
harsh on the large weights and much less
on the small weights it kind of
proportionally spreads over the weights
across all the Neons it it then ensures
that process is
smoother so then finally the sparsity
aspect when it comes to L1 the sparcity
is high because the model also performs
feature selection so it sets certain
weights equal to zero which means that
it also automatically perform swi
selection and it then reduces that the
dimension of the model and makes the
network
sparser whereas in case of a two or re
regularization the sparcity is low
because the regularization process is
not performing future selection and it
has no zero
weights the next question is how do L1
and L2 regularization impact the weights
in narrow network uh when it comes to
comparing the impact on large versus
small weight
penalizations so in here we can just
summarize at high level given that we
went into detail of this as part of
previous questions that L2 as the square
of the weights as a penalty and as a
result the large weights are heavily
punished so they are reduced versus the
small weights which are not so heavily
and harshly reduced this means that the
L2 will distribute the error along and
among all the weights and this will lead
to smaller but nonzero weights and it
will kind of proportionally spread over
all the weights across the
neurons now when it comes to the L1
regularization L1 significantly reduces
the magnitude of the weights so large
versus small weights the reduction of
the of the weights when it comes to the
large weights is much smaller so the L2
L1 regularization is less harsh on the
large weights compared to thisal weights
so given that we are using this absolute
vol Val of the weights it means that it
will the algorithm will be effectively
remove the features from the model by
setting certain weights exactly equal to
zero and those are usually the weights
that have already been small so it will
penalize more harshly those small
weights and it will be very harsh on
them but not so much on the large
weights and in this way we will end up
removing those small weights by setting
them equal to zero and keeping only
those large weights the next question is
what is the curse of dimensionality in
machine learning or in AI so the curse
of dimensionality is a nonn phenomena in
machine learning especially when we are
dealing with this distance-based
neighborhood based models like KNN or
cines and we need to compute this
distance using distance measures such as
aine distance cosign distance Manhattan
distance and whenever we have have uh
High dimensional data so we have many
features in our data then the model
starts to really suffer from the Cur of
dimensionality so the complexity Rises
when the model needs to compute these
distances between the the set of pairs
but given that we have so many features
it becomes problematic and sometimes
even invisible to obtain those distances
and
and obtaining and calculating these
distances in some cases doesn't even
make sense because they no longer
reflect the actual pairwise relationship
or the distance between those two pair
of observations when we have so many
features and that's what we are calling
the curse of dimensionality so we have a
curse on our ml or AI model when we have
high dimension and when we want to
compute this distance between pair of
observ ations and this can introduce
data sparsity this can introduce
computational challenges can introduce a
risk of overfitting for our problem the
model becomes less
generalizable and it will also become
problem in terms of picking a distance
measure that can handle this high
dimension of our data how deep learning
models tackle the course of
dimensionality so when it comes to the
Deep learning models unlike the machine
learning learning models deep learning
models do not suffer from this problem
so machine learning models they need to
for them to work properly with high
dimensional data they need to perform
feature selection they sometimes
recommend to use different sorts of
feature selection techniques such as
forward stepwise selection backward
stepwise selection mix selections or
other type of feature selection
techniques or dimensionality reduction
techniques such as PCA or factor
analysis in order to to reduce the
dimension of our features before even
providing them as an input to our
machine learning model this is not
necessarily for our deep learning models
Because deep learning models are able to
counter this course of dimensionality by
learning this useful feature
representations and reducing this data
Dimension that we have uh applying
regularization and also using
architecture specifically designed for
high dimension data so
basically we don't need to perform
feature selection when it comes to uh
using this complex and high dimensional
data in the Deep learning Because deep
learning models are specifically
designed to be able to learn complex
dependencies in the features nonlinear
patterns so they do not need feature
selection techniques to perform that for
them and instead they just use
techniques regularization techniques
such as L1 regularization so L of
regular ation to not only perform
regularization but also to perform
future selection as part of the deep
learning models itself so few ways that
the Deep learning models can prevent
this curse of dimensionality and the way
that they do not suffer from this curse
of
dimensionality is by performing feature
learning as part of the actual original
Deep learning process um so it also uses
this dimensionality reduction techniques
for instance uses outo encoders
variational outo encoders to compress
the input
data and represent the input data with
this compressed form like the
dimensionality reduction technique but
now as part of the actual architecture
of deep learning model and then learn
the hidden factors from this already
compressed data with lower Dimension and
then reconstruct from this to get the
final output
now another way that it does is by using
regularization methods and I briefly
spoke about this uh just before by for
instance using L1 regularization because
L1 regularization reduces the sparcity
uh and introduces sparcity by reducing
the dimension of the of the features by
setting some of the weights equal to
zero it indirectly performs feature
selection and finally if we use model
such as CNN and we use pulling layers so
pulling layers in convolution neural
networks for instance they automatically
perform feature selection and they
reduce the dimensionality of the problem
and in this way they automatically
combat the curse of dimensionality the
next question is what are generative
models give examples so let's first
start with the generative models so
generative models aim to model how data
is
generated they want to learn the uh
joint probability distribution what we
are often referring as P X and Y which
is the joint probability distribution of
two random variables X and Y where X
represent the features of our data and
why represent the
labels so what generative models do is
that they try to model the underlying
data distribution so they want to figure
out how data was generated in the first
place and in this way they can then
generate new data instances and they can
also predict
probabilities and beside this generative
models are also great when it comes to
unsupervised learning tasks so from
machine learning you are most likely
familiar with this idea of supervised
versus unsupervised when in case of
supervised we do have the label so the Y
values but in case of the unsupervised
case we don't have labels to supervisor
learning process which means that we
need to perform the learning only using
the features think about clustering
think about outlier detection or
dimensionality reduction or some data
Generation all these cases can be
considered as unsupervised learning
tasks and generative models are great in
doing
so now when it comes to the generative
models they are particularly useful in
scenarios when we want to understand and
we need to understand the underlying
data distribution or when we need to
generate new data points so let's say
you want to generate synthetic data or
you have lot of images and you want to
generate new images images that do make
sense and they are similar to the input
data but they are new they are noic they
are fresh and this can be done by using
generative models and all the models
that these days you hear about
for instance the GPT
series uh the variational auto encoders
the gens so generative adval series uh
networks all these models they are
generative models and they are largely
used for generating new images
generating synthetic data um for
generating new speech for instance when
there is a data that is there is a model
that is trained on the large amount of
of the speech you provide for examples
of your speech and then the model is
able to generate new voice so recording
of based on the text based on your own
voice but you haven't yet spoken that
that's generative model that is doing
that